TV up next live in-depth with author
playwright and essayist gore Vidal in a
writing career spanning over 50 years
gore Vidal has produced 22 novels more
than 200 essays a memoir and numerous
short stories and screenplays this month
one of his plays has been revived on
Broadway and the seventh installment in
his american chronicle series a novel
called the golden age has been released
here to join us on book tv's in-depth
series to talk about his life and work
as gore vidal's mr. Badal thanks for
being here very nice to be here in my
hometown do you remember the first time
you put pen to paper
I sort of remember I must have been
about six or seven and I have starting
to read fairly grown-up books and I had
read a book I didn't like children's
books but I had been given one called
the duck and the kangaroo a tale of
unnatural affection the duck was in love
of the kangaroo and I immediately
started to write a book what I thought
was a book it turned out to be pretty
much the duck in the kangaroo but I
think that was the beginning that when I
saw something that triggered him his
movie called the mystery of the Blue
Room I think it was and that really
started me off on about eight or nine
and I really sat down to write a novel
didn't get terribly far then when I was
about 16 I used to go over the Library
of Congress and I wrote half a book I
don't know what on earth it was about
but I just go to everyday and write rest
of the time I was reading
and what time there was left I was
reading aloud to my grandfather senator
Gore who was with whom I live pretty
much died I was 10 and he was blind from
the age of 10 and he got me a read for
him and I was the I was his favorite
grandchild or child because I loved
reading and his other children hated it
and he used to chuckle rather grimly
after I'd been reading for five or six
hours on n said you know if John
Milton's daughters went blind reading to
their father he could chuckle appellate
to himself and now let's get to
bimetallism this is an exciting subject
free silver you see was the basis of my
founding the state of Oklahoma this was
and would be off to the races so I was
getting great history lessons along with
reading skills and it was a what was
nice about it I got to talk to him
grandfather's particulars or senators
and blind and have to be looked after
aren't the best of company but I was his
reader so I came in to another guy
wasn't just a grandchild I was a reading
person and he held them in high regard
let me tell our audience a little bit
about what we'll be doing this afternoon
and how they can join in in this this
series called in depth we have the
opportunity to spend three full hours
with authors who have spent many years
writing and producing books
gore Vidal will be with us for the next
three hours we'll be talking for about
20 to 25 minutes and then opening up our
phone lines for your questions for him
from all around the country we'll put
that phone number on the bottom of the
screen during this first half hour so
you can begin thinking about your
questions and calling into our Studios
here in Washington and we do very much
welcome your participation lots of
opportunity for discussions of all sorts
when did you decide that writing would
be your career I don't think I ever
decided
I wanted to go into politics that was
the family's trade and I sort of aimed
more toward that but that made something
of a historian out of me because I kept
studying the issues as I went along my
grandfather was born in 1870 so between
his life in my life we've covered half
that of the Republic and he had
memorized as far back as the revolution
from a great-grandfather of his so I it
was natural for me to write and as
natural as it was for me to read I had
no clear idea I was a very much a poet
and very bad poet very didactic
and thundering but in my back of my mind
I just the need to invent world's was
obviously pretty great so I became a
writer in the army I was in the Pacific
during the war I enlisted at the age of
17 in the year 1943 and ended up as a
first mate of an army boat in the
Aleutian Islands where I got soaked one
day by way for the Bering Sea
hypothermia is at the word for it anyway
I came out of it with rheumatoid
arthritis in the Army Hospital I began
to write need to say about the first
mate of Army boat in the Aleutian
Islands I was in the traditional mode
write about what you know I was by then
eighteen or nineteen and as usual I
tried to write and I was at Exeter at
least six novels and some of them I got
very far along and then the side could
never finish anything so here I was
writing this narrative about the
Aleutians
the experience of a great storm which is
called williwaw in the Aleut language
and what it was like to be all of those
men running 20 man crew in this forlorn
lunar landscape was these dangerous seas
in extraordinary beaches beaches up in
illusions are covered with moonstone and
Jasper and also its precious stones no
indigenous wildlife except for foxes and
great black Ravens and a lot of a lot of
guys went crazy up there really in the
Quonset huts because you never saw the
sound of it I didn't go crazy because I
had a book to her story so in the army
hospital I didn't get much done then
they made me a mess officer and camp
Gordon Johnson Apalachicola Florida
transportation Corps and that was kind
of fun
I wouldn't let me out I could have had a
medical discharge which they said will
keep you in two more years because you
can still do work like this and one
night I went to see a movie called Isle
of the Dead with Boris Karloff and it
was a not as a monster but as a Greek
colonel an island in which there is a
kind of mad spirit abroad wonderful
picture and after I saw the picture I
when I was officer the day today I was
on duty at night in the headquarters and
I went back it was great I course had
all the lights on I remember why and
there were rows of typewriters and I
went over and started typing and within
a week I'd finished will my first book
that I had ever complete
in due course after three years of the
army I was let out in 46 gave it to a
publisher and it was published it's not
just that it was complete but did you
know that in fact it was good I thought
I had accomplished what I set out to do
yes naturally I was compared to
Hemingway everybody was compared to
having where in those days if you wrote
in a sort of abbreviated terse style but
the reading I have been doing that
influenced me if anything did other than
my imaginary world and the real world
I'm describing it would have been hard
cranes the boat which I've never seen I
finally met somebody who had noticed
that I was being interviewed in New York
and the interviewer said you know I got
my master's degree in college in your
book willawaw I said tell me about it
native you had totally forgotten it
he said reread it so maybe I will but
not on air when you look at your
relationship with Senator Gore do you
think that was the formative
relationship in your life oh yes
aside from a passion for politics which
seems to be in the bloodstream of most
Gore's as we are witnessing this year he
gave me a profound sense of history from
the losers side he was from Mississippi
and the Gores come from northern
Mississippi in our burgers family comes
from Tennessee just across the border
from us so all the same family and we
were unionists there were no slaves up
there and we didn't want to secede and
eastern Tennessee did not secede but all
of Mississippi did and my
great-grandfather thundergirls father
enlisted with two brothers and in due
course he was wounded at Chickamauga and
taken camp
and while his other brothers was was
killed so my grandfather was the nag his
son he became County Clerk
without my grandfather was just able to
tell me about the civil war what it was
like what the Yankees did when I came
and burned the town and with that
history and that politics a writer's
subject was born if not a writer would
you describe your politics well I
wouldn't have written so many books if I
could describe it in one sentence would
I I come out of the populist tradition
which was his tradition populist means
people and we there was let me call the
party of the people at the end of the
19th century one of the principal
organizers in that area was my great
grandfather gore and the holy wars for
political and many of them great artists
well it was a party to represent first
the people who had been ruined by the
Civil War southerners just ruling
farmers and the Bourbons of the southern
as they call the aristocrats of the
Southern Mississippi they had lost
plantations and so on but somehow they
held on to money we had nothing up in
the north so in order to organize
against reconstruction that the bad
aspects of it and the card cold hand of
the banks in the north who were buying
up the south and exploiting keeping
cotton at five cents or whatever was
playing around with a with our crops and
money we became violently anti big banks
what we call corporate America today
that was those were the villains and he
continued along that line in due course
populist were co-opted by the Democratic
Party and William Jennings Bryan three
times
for president Ellis the heroic leader of
the party my grandfather nominated him
for president in nineteen oh seven or
eight I guess it was at Denver and he
remembered Bryan was 36 weeks first
nominated sort of a windbag but a
marvelous ardor and my grandfather said
the thing about Bryan is he never
developed after he made his cross of
gold you shall not press down upon the
power of proud labor this crown of
thorns you shall not crucify mankind
upon across a cold the gore is naturally
were free silver which was what my metal
ISM was all about my grandmother started
the longest demonstration in the history
of any convention when he nominated
Bryan how long was it you know I think
is about two hours a two-hour
demonstration and I praise it up and
down the place went crazy because and he
was speaking as the new senator of a new
state which he'd helped to create
Oklahoma and so he was a great novel and
he was a great orator he said as they
were driving away from the convention it
wasn't that convention it was the next
time Bryan was nominated Bryan ran and
lost I guess it was the next time as
they were driving away in their carriage
from the convention hall Bryan said you
know I tribute my success in politics to
just three things my god was I can't
remember anything he said I do remember
thinking why he thought he was a success
about 15 minutes until we begin your
phone calls for Gore Vidal's
and then here are the numbers he live in
the eastern half of the United States
two zero two six two four eleven eleven
if you live in the mountain or Pacific
time zones two zero two six two four
eleven fifteen
I was surprised in my reading to learn
that in fact Gore was not your birth
name that you took it as a writer it's
not true that's not true
I was christened by the Canon Albert
Holly Lucas headmaster of st. Albans
where I was in school
it was christened uh Eugene Luther gore
Vidal
so you chose to emphasize no that's too
long like you can't use that as a
writers name I was going to go into
politics in the state of New Mexico and
was making certain preparations for it
when I was in my 20s and I just got the
eugene luther off after all my father
was gene I didn't want to be another
gene fond as I was of him and Luther
just doesn't work so we kept to
Gorbachov I did have in the back of my
mind that if I were to run for office he
was a great power in that section in the
southwest and a friend of his in fact we
used to talk about that in 48 I'd been
out of the army two years published my
first two books I would go to New Mexico
Fae settle in the governor was a protege
of my grandfather's Jack Dempsey was his
name and I would settle in and become a
politician and Vidal is a Latin name
which is a help with the Hispanic vote
although my family was Italian but so
that is how I got the name or gave
myself the name by cutting it off the
first two two words what is your
specific relationship to Al Gore well
we've never met but I knew his father I
love it now every time I'm on a program
or a distant cousin of Albert Gore well
we're not distant at all I had not
wanted to meet him because it doesn't do
you much good if you're a political
commentator to be thought to be involved
with the president I discovered that
during Jack Kennedy's reign when
suddenly I was not taken seriously at
all having been taken quite seriously
as a commentator because they thought
that I was apologist for him and that
was because it was irresistible not to
make fun of Richard Nixon so it seems as
though I was partisan when I wasn't but
I figured out then it does no good to be
attached in any way to a political
figure if you want to talk about
politics which I tend to do so I had a
kind of young Albert was going to make
himself president if he could and though
I liked his father and his father my
grandfather were friends we're all here
in Washington I mean you can't say it
with distant cousins we're all I'd lost
last night I had wonderful dinner with
Deborah Gore Dean another cousin and
she's she's the granddaughter of Grady
score so there's Grady Gore here in the
town with a Fairfax hotel he's the rich
member of the family
there's Albert Gore from eastern
Tennessee comes here in the house and
then goes on to the Senate and there's
Thomas Pryor gore from Mississippi but
senator from Oklahoma
bro all three cousins are here in the
town and they all three knew each other
I'm talking the older generation so it's
a sudden there's a saying in Mississippi
there's a snake bites Agoura they all
pop up you know you mentioned Debra
Gordon you're your cousin's people who
follow politics closely we'll remember
that she had some troubles during the
Reagan administration huh I would think
since she was young she was foolish she
went she wanted to work for Ronald
Reagan that's that's trouble enough and
Acting President
how's she in fact disavowed herself in
public life after that experience I
haven't talked about public life is a
wonderful decorator a decorator now she
has her over in Georgetown that
wonderful alone
shop there well speaking of public life
you talked about your aspirations to
politics she ran twice would you talk
about those two bids and what happened
well the first oh I I like to read about
my humiliating defeat right-wing
specialty I doubled the vote in 1964
Congress from our state New York the
29th congressional district which is
five counties very big district and in
fact it harry truman come up to
introducing during an event there came
up to speak for because i introduced him
and in 1959 I'd written a play called
the best man and I gave it to Jack
Kennedy to read he was running for
president I was running for the house
and your eye your eye contact is gone
because I'm showing the audience the
best man flyer which is just really as
everything is behind me on this program
what is going on up stage there I feel
it is old way of life gladiators are
fighting while I'm down stage what did
it were that interesting
I'm not we'll do our best to enliven the
downstage here
well in fact I interrupted you right at
the best man being written 1959 you can
pick it up from there so I am running
for Congress Jack is running for
president the best man which is once
again on Broadway the Virginia theater
and Manhattan this was in a census study
of presidential character as a character
somewhat like Adlai Stevenson some
something like Truman something like
Nixon and it was written really such as
I helped out Jack because he had it
today
Nixon would be his opponent if he got
the nomination and it was very very
important that he get knock off Adlai
Stevenson who had had two runs and we
are the liberal end of the Democratic
our overall Steven so nians and suddenly
Jack is the insurgent but after two runs
we thought that Adlai Stevenson was just
not up to it he was a very cultivated
charming man
wonderful speech maker but he was not
decisive and his great back it was
Eleanor Roosevelt who was my neighbor of
Madison and she adored him and she was
she one of the party to support him she
didn't like Jack Kennedy one bit first
he was a McCarthy ID in her eyes very
friendly with Joe McCarthy and of course
he detested his father which shouldn't
have held over with him but it did and I
remembered Jack's and her son Frank
Roosevelt jr. Walter Reuther who's head
of the United Auto Workers and me to pay
a call on her to Al Queda cottage to get
her to support
addley I was sort jack and she ran a
position paper to us which was my day
for the next week and they said yes but
she won't make up his mind you keep
proposing him he'd say you know you know
no I don't know if I'm running or not
well she said finally Frank Roosevelt
said you know mom we don't want you
can't have somebody who doesn't know his
own mind she said well that's the way he
is you can't change people he said well
we know that's the way is we don't want
him secondly that she went right on to
to support Adlai Stevenson going to the
convention wave your finger at us you
must support this man I'm losing my
thing in my ear that's tell the audience
that's how you're going to hear phone
calls and I hear the phone calls which
I'm sure are loud enough so I
practically hear a phone call now
they're lined up for using from and in
fact how is the presidency different
today as you rerelease this play from
the kind of presidency you captured it
in 90
sixty in the Jack Kennedy era when it
certainly makes a monkey out of Darwin
there's been no evolution in 40 years
the audience recognizes these types my
character as they sits there it's sort
of a thriller and it's quite funny
people don't know they've forgotten
about realism life is not always tragic
and it's not always coming it's a sort
of mixture and that is what realism was
now everybody thinks all series players
got to be lugubrious and the comedy has
got to be fat falls
real life is mixed and it's it is a
realistic play and the audience's pick
up on just about I haven't changed the
word since 1960 so it's like a time
machine for them they're walking into a
1960 meaning in which you watch over
three-day period at this convention
whose consume and fighting it out with
an old president being the decisive
voice and they ask a lot of questions
they compare it to today when a
convention means nothing because by
March of 2000 we knew who the two
candidates were and you don't get the
convention until June or July so it's
quite different also we don't talk about
money in the play there's no hard money
soft money no electoral reform so I
should probably touched upon delicately
amusingly with you Lee in the play than
have been in this entire campaign as we
sit here in Washington DC with
presidential candidates roaming the
country first telephone call for you is
from Philadelphia welcome to the program
and you're on for gore vidal's yes hello
mr. Badal you know I'm honored to speak
with you I met James Baldwin on your
birthday the year before he died and I
told him it was your birthday and he
said he didn't know and he didn't say
anything about the fact that you all
knew each other until I read your memoir
I realized that you didn't know each
other so I was wondering if you two ever
talk politics and if so how did you find
him and if not
how did you find mr. Baldwin generally
well I like Jimmy and I worked here my
first book willawaw came out 1946
EP Dutton the publisher gave me a job as
as a reader and I brought them cry holy
a book by Jane Jimmy Baldwin which later
became go tell it on the mountain the
head of EP Dutton mr. McCray just took
when he found out the author was blacks
but don't you understand I am from
Virginia I said well what's that got to
do with it well he turned it down on the
grounds that he was not going to publish
a black author first time I'd ever seen
it that close Jimmy went on however to
publish elsewhere and did very well
relations with Jimmy himself were always
kind of edgy he was he had a lot of
problems on the one hand he was a
wonderful sort of orator and a great
sermon Iser the other hand he was just
in love with showbiz so he would go for
Martin Luther King on one day to Betty
Davis on the next day was very odd
dealing with such a mercurial of
character but I thought he he was a
great voice in his time but I'm not so
sure the novels will be remembered I was
looking at one of them the other day and
it seemed very sort of showbiz novels
that he wrote but the sermons still hold
up next call for you comes from a town
that's been in the news quite a bit
lately Los Alamos New Mexico welcome to
the program thank you first off I want
to say when you began this series I was
always hoping you would have gore Badal
for three hours and mr. Badal you
mentioned all of the dead earlier which
is one of my favorite movies and the
book I particularly enjoyed the viewers
was screening history in your opening
line you say as I now move graciously I
hope toward the door marked exit it
occurs to me that the only thing I ever
really liked to do was go to the movies
and my sentiments exactly
so mom a question for you mr. Badal
which it's a great honor to speak to you
is have you seen any good movies lately
I think keep seeing them and I keep
forgetting their names there was a good
Altman movie I'm a member of the Academy
so I vote on the Oscars and so I get I
get to see everything there's a very
good Altman movie last year which had
the word cookie in the title the ones I
like and seldom are seldom very
successful but I think we've got a lot
of interesting movie makers now I like
the Coen Brothers
it's like Tim Robbins I worked as an
actor with Tim Robbins and Bob Roberts I
think is good political movie and I went
to Los Alamos when it was a boys school
I was there 39 to 40 and up there on the
Mesa just now been burnt a bit and kind
of awful plays and ten years before I
got there there was another writer to be
William Burroughs so the Los Alamos
produced burrows and Vidal I don't know
what that means
if you have some free time right now
would you choose to read or go to the
movies I do both because as a member of
the Academy I get everything Bradford on
videocassette so I play that and I'm
reading all the time as well there's
much time to do anything but look and
read before we take the next clock we
talk a little bit about homes when did
you choose Italy as your your major
place of residence I don't know some
major and I spent all last winter I have
a house in Los Angeles Hollywood Hills
and I make the tired joke arguably
between Hollywood and Ravello Italy you
can say I don't live in America at all
as America is in my head and as America
is my subject and wherever I am there is
American
I sometimes think I've limited myself in
a way being so intensely interested in
the country and in its politics and in
the design of its history which is what
please and I never called an American
Chronicle that was publishers I call
them narratives of empire from burda
Lincoln to 1876 right up to the the
Golden Age what I'm doing is trying to
find a design in our history I'm trying
to find how deliberate was the
acquisition of empire was there a plan
or were there many similar plans that
coalesced into this global empire that
is causing the world so much trouble and
is so expensive for us to maintain and I
think toward the end of that obsessed I
just saw the book palimpsest and I say
the title of the Golden Age I begin to
draw a pattern Italy is a place just to
go to to write and Hollywood Hills is a
place to what I'm living in America from
which I politic and sometimes do the odd
movie if we were to find you in Ravello
writing where exactly would you be I'd
be in my studio in a villa which is
about 700 meters above the sea it's on a
cliff with a spectacular view of the
Gulf Coast Salerno in front of me and
right across the Gulf there's past the
Greek temples from the 5th century out a
clear day you think you can see the but
I don't think we do see them and I would
be there sitting in a cube room cube
like room take it wife
writing in longhand on yellow legal
sheets no computer no computer how do
you revise I haven't typed up i fax it
to London where I have a typist she
factors it backed me she's got a floppy
disk and I do another version I do
generally about five or six versions of
everything sometimes I try to cheat and
stop at four and it's not right so that
is the work process when do you do your
best work are you a morning person oh
yeah when I get up which might not be
morning but I find it not only the
closer you are to the dream state that
you've been in before awakening the much
ready or the imagination is not to
mention memory with age you begin to
start to forget names and numbers and so
on I find that if I've got a problem and
I can't think of something and if I just
put it on hold in the morning it comes
to me I had the name that I was looking
for or the book that I'm trying to find
Graham Greene said something about the
same thing he used to have a house on
Anna Capri capris just up the coast from
us and he said that any problem he had
was always solved the next morning when
he got out because I regarded Graham's
wonderful man and sometimes a good
writer but what we call an easy settler
in the movie business that means
somebody who does a first draft okay
that's it is perfect Huntsville Alabama
you're on for gore Vidal mr. Badal it
it's an honor to talk to you sir can I
can I stop you for a second you're
having a little bit of feedback as your
televisions up too high and that's
what's causing the problem for you start
it down and then go ahead with your
question
well I know you went to one of the most
exclusive prep schools in the US but -
what do your tributes you're brilliant I
like some pointers on how you could
write a book as brilliant as the
judgment of Paris
well it certainly had nothing to do with
any school I ever went to I went to st.
Albans here and Exeter up in New
Hampshire I have never been so bored in
my life I had one or two good teachers
at both places but the courses I mean
the boredom that they inflicted this is
a period where you had to learn by rote
memorized memorized
I remember innocently when I got to
Exeter I said so when are we going to
get to the Roman Empire we don't get to
the Roman Empire you'll be translating
Julius Caesar that's all we do they
taught nothing of interest to me and my
marks were very bad and I barely passed
what they call then the College Board
exams but instead at 17 I listed in the
army I never went back to school I was
supposed to go to Harvard I came back I
did go to Harvard after my first book
came out to lecture and there in the
audience were at least 10 boys that I
had been to extra been with it Exeter
who were very old undergraduates having
just come out of the War veterans and
that was a triumphal moment or not that
I had gone my own way not going to
university if I am in a way brilliant or
if I'm in any way learning it's perhaps
a better word
I was in the habit of reading all my
life with a man who was part of history
and a historian as well
and I was immersed in literature and in
history and I never stopped reading and
I'm always trying to find out things I
wanted to know everything when I was a
kid I remember I used to make charts the
history of the world and they now do
them but they didn't exist then in which
in the first century you'd find out what
they were doing in age of what they were
doing in China what the doing in North
America comparative history I just
thought that up as I'd make these
enormous charts then fill in the various
centuries I think well I am what they
call an autodidact I taught myself and
as somebody said to me an Oregon
recently went missing after speech
autodidact have gone to the wrong
schools of this guy from Harvard I said
well let others be the judge next is the
call from Seattle hi I'm in in 1971 you
wrote an article that was a cover story
for Esquire magazine and and it's
supported Ralph Nader for president and
I was wondering if you were Isis
supporter of his current campaign no Tim
Robbins and Susan Sarandon are great
friends of mine and I just had dinner
together they're supporting Nader and
many of my friends are obviously the
idea is that he is a virtuous figure and
is not going to be elected but he might
through his candidacy this year set up a
Green Party which would be useful in
future years well that's the third party
route I've done that and was dr. Spock
the People's Party in 1968 70
I don't see any future in that we've
we've got one political party which is
corporate America's possession it has
two right wings Democratic Party
Democratic wing Republican way I'm
really interested in not in a third
party but in getting us a second party
as they got back in 1856 when all the
splits started in the Republican Party
was invented and did a great job for the
United States so I'm for that really
rather than a third fourth fifth
Buchanan party of his party a native
party
and then when asked the question by the
price I said well at the end of the day
I think gore is thicker than Nader when
you mention your current thinking or
that America is essentially corporate
America you mentioned earlier that this
is a theme that runs throughout the
series in fact has it always been a
situation of the powerful interest
versus the people yes and it is really
the essential conflict in American life
and it's the real party system no matter
what the official parties are there is
the line of Jefferson and there's the
line of Hamilton Hamilton was for big
industry banking National Bank world
trade forcing ourselves upon other
people if necessary we got Jefferson was
the mind your own business
more agricultural life more bucolic and
most Americans are Jeffersonians only
the bankers at least at the time of
World War One World War two were
interventionist Americans do not want to
go abroad to be killed in other
countries sometimes countries they've
never heard of before you asked me
earlier about my politics well it is
anti-imperialist
and I'm certainly I'm not anti banking
that would be flat earth politics we
must have that but it must be kept in
back
and our problem is that they they are
the masters and they have bought the
politicians just look at this year
they're going to be a million dollars
half a million anyway hey Don this
election an election that nobody's going
to bother with if they can help it
because they're not interested the
candidates whether they are intelligent
like my cousin Albert or if they are
somewhat disturbed or disturbing like
his opponent basically don't differ much
and have nothing to say because the
people who give them the money to run
don't want them to address real issues
what is a real issue there's only one
thing to talk about in the year 2000 and
that is for 50 years we have been a
militarized economy a garrison state we
spent over seven trillion dollars since
1949 on war that is the theme of my
American Chronicle Isis is called how
the people on the one hand are left
behind and are exploited in the early
days by Eastern banks now is of course
as if it's the great corporations that
only country by the politicians the
corruption is total now when corruption
is systemic you can't say well Bush is
corrupt or Gore is corrupt or this one
or that one the whole system is corrupt
the whole means of raising money
well this starting out with Berg you see
the fight my first novel and not serious
you see the fight going on between Berg
and Jefferson on these very issues and
the fight particularly Hamilton and
these two men Hamilton and Jefferson
defined American life
Jefferson is with the people the
Hamilton is with the Aristo Zoar the
great business magnate and this is a
struggle except the Hamiltonians have
won now what you should talk about is
why 51 percent of our budget 1999 went
for war went to the Pentagon they are
now demanding 30 billion
a year more over the next decade now
we're getting away from books I'm going
to give a political speech you told me
before the program started that you just
spent some time calculating how much
money this country has allocated to
weaponry yes over what period and what's
the number I just gave it to you I just
this instant you gave it to me I
apologize say again seven point one
trillion dollars has gone for war since
1949 and we have had no enemy except the
ones we selected as far as I know the
Vietcong never attacked us we attacked
them in the interest of Corporate
America there were a lot of ties between
great corporations and South Vietnam we
interfered in their civil war in their
affairs and we have suffered greatly
same thing with Korea's 49 it was one of
the big build-up started Harry Truman
Berlin them peacetime drafting enormous
amount of monies for the military and it
was so it's all quite delivery he used
the fact that Greece and Turkey this is
about 1950 might fall to the Russian
bear because England had been protecting
Greece and Aemon was broke we must take
their place and he and Dean Acheson who
was this is all in the golden age so
those interested in the subject may turn
to that but they got together and
decided to make a real issue that the
Russians are coming the Russians were
coming communism is a great danger the
United States will communism was a great
danger to the Russians and to live
people their satellite state they were
no danger ties but officially the good
reason for the build-up was that Truman
Acheson were afraid we'd fall back into
the depression we didn't get out of the
depression until 1940 when we started to
arm to go to war against Hitler and
Japan struck at us that ended the
depression now they're beginning to see
dicey times coming they loved General
Motors that had what's good for General
Motors is good for the country said the
chairman of the board and that meant war
spend nothing but war ever since one
historian put it very nicely in one
phrase our policy is perpetual war for
perpetual peace and that is insanity
that is why we have the worst public
educational system in the first world
that's why we have no health care for
the people people get nothing back for
their tax money this is a populist line
that you're hearing from me and that is
a theme of many of my books we get
nothing back except all this armament
and lately of you been reading the
papers the Chiefs of the various
services are demanding more and more
money because it's all deteriorating and
there is no enemy we create enemies we
blow up an aspirin factory in the Sudan
but if the Sudanese had any power they'd
probably blow up a factory here but they
don't and they won't and we go right on
we have the number one terrorist on
earth and now you and through my series
of seven books you see this evolution
and how the American people were left
out decisions were made over their heads
by the equivalent of corporate America
back in the 18th century and that
nowadays if we have no redress because
we have no representative government one
senator if you remember scoop Jackson
Zoe's the senator from Boeing not the
senator from Washington that's what
happened to us so if we were to have a
real election we'll be discussing what
I've just been discussing our next
caller who is from Pittsburgh has a
question about burr the first in that
series
all right it's a great pleasure talking
to you amazing bird I've read about a
half a dozen of your books and they've
all bought me great pleasure and
entertainment in and information about
burr
uh I've drawn a parallel if you will in
school I had learned that in about the
ninth grade I learned that a bird had
killed Alexander Hamilton when he was
vice president knobs and Hammer was
secretary of the Treasury but they never
told us why and I didn't find out why I
read your book it is and they do neglect
these details and I and it's and I have
correlated I figured the nice as well
like two hundred years later we're still
doing the same thing what we would have
of course President Clinton brought that
mess on himself but you had some people
behind the scenes putting pamphlets out
about his activities which is why burst
shot Hamilton he had instigated a
pamphlet about him yes one more thing
live from Gaul Gotha which is another
one my another one of your favorite
books that I like at the end of it
there's a Japanese script and could you
you'd be hint this what it was is but
we're giving away the plot of life from
gal Gotha but NBC is gone back to
Calvary they can get through a time warp
to film the crucifixion and suddenly
there's been a takeover corporate
takeover of NBC and of most media in
America by the Japanese and throw at the
very end instead of the agony and the
passion of Jesus you see the Japanese
goddess the mother goddess of the world
suddenly appears on the screen and the
entire past is being changed and there
will be no more Jesus only the Japanese
mother goddess so the book ends with two
pages of Japanese celebrating her virtue
and the fact she's all-powerful have any
further comments for him on burr on
birth well the allegations that I
figured out but did not I you
I don't make reckless guesses about what
people didn't didn't do if I don't have
something to go on
Bert read in the papers that Hamilton
was a defeated politician at this point
was still making a lot of trouble had
written of friends saying there is
something I can tell you about Colonel
Burris character which is of such a
despicable nature that I can only
confine it to you in private subs and
paraphrasing the letter well I thought
and I thought and I thought what on
earth could be Burr has a Heidemann
elephant he was a coolest man of his
time and one of the brightest the only
thing the love of his life was his
daughter Theodosian his only only
legitimate job and he had brought her up
he was probably the first feminists in
the United States he said women have the
same minds as men if they are educated
like men so he educated her personally
as as if she were a son she became a
brilliant woman and and he was so close
to her that they were like buddies and
his letters which finally got printed
but were known about for to her letters
of two young men writing each other I
mean he writes about all of his sex life
in Paris in some detail and he treats
her as a son he thought of himself as
Lord Chesterfield writing to a son his
closest - Theodosia was known to
everybody and i intuited that hamilton
had said something about incest Hamilton
would Hamilton was reckless and ran off
at the mouth nothing else would have led
burr vice president United States to
call out Hamilton in a duel and she can
kill him at Weehawken
well a lot of outcry when I wrote this
you know I made a note I said I am
making a guess here but nobody else has
come up with anything the current there
are two books out now about that period
and one by a profession fogulson forget
his name acknowledges but he he too
thinks for that what is what happened
and he's got some evidence in this
latest biography of birth so here we are
seven thirty years later and the
official historians are acknowledging
that my intuition was probably correct
can we spend a minute talking about the
entirety of the series when you began it
has you plotted out what you wanted to
do which figures you were going to
address no it just it just ambled along
I first one to be written was actually
the last one till now it was Washington
DC I was written in 67 and it covered
the period of of Roosevelt's
administration but I kept Roosevelt and
so on in the background and my fictional
characters were very much in the
foreground as of 30s and into up to
Eisenhower to about 54 that was 67 and
then I decided I started to brood about
it and I thought first of all I was
teaching myself a lot in American
history and I got interested well how
what how did Roosevelt pull it off how
did he get us into the second world war
we all knew that he had manipulated the
Japanese into attacking us but how and
why and then what what was there abroad
in the land what mechanism what that he
could touch to create opinion as David
Hume would say that would convince the
people that this war was a just war
Hitler of course was it was a great
monster but it's not necessary for us
it's a great line of John Quincy Adams
he says the United States
18:20 the United States
does not go forth to destroy monsters
yes he could become dictators of the
world but in the process she would lose
her own soul you asked me for my
politics is that is pure populism coming
from a New England Federalist but of
like mind we have enough to do
perfecting our society without going
forth to slay monsters that was pretty
much the trigger thinking about how
Roosevelt got to be Roosevelt and we got
possession of the world so I went down I
think I'll go back to the beginning so I
go back to the revolution and the most
attractive figure to me is Aaron Burr he
was also a relative of my stepfather and
I'd always known that he had a bum rap
from the family but I didn't know who or
what he was and whoever was one of one
of your callers said you know what a
mess they make of American history in
school they fought a burr a duel but you
don't know why nor would they try to
guess so I go back to the revolution I
go back to Washington and Hamilton
Jefferson ferb and he has a very
sardonic style and I and I used a lot of
his own writings then I move on to our
great tragic period and President
Lincoln and I'm able to bring in it a
great deal of what it felt like to be on
the losers side it's by the south I
think is produced some of the
interesting writers once you have lost a
war Payne has has a great resonance for
you then I go on to 1876 which is the
centennial of the country and we were
once again steeped in corruption the
Democrat governor Tilden of New York
wins the election by I think 200,000
votes popular vote the Republicans who
are still in some of the southern states
and then the Far West in control of
legislatures reversed the election
and rutherford Behe's who lost it
becomes a Republican president brother
be rather be fraud he was known as
that's 1876 and you get a sense then I
was a centennial and there we go on to
Empire which shows the plan being made
by Theodore Roosevelt and we have at
large Brooks Adams brother of Henry
Adams a brilliant geopolitician to
create an admiral man whether the
theories about sea power we deliberately
picked a war with Spain which was a very
weak but imperial power we defeated
Spain we grabbed Cuba we grabbed Puerto
Rico best of all we got the Philippines
right off the coast of Asia that makes
us at the Civic power which was the
dream of zero of the imperialist the
jingoes the might politically I'm
opposed to out of that came first big
elements that we had done since the
Civil War the Great White Fleet of
Theodore Roosevelt
then we got meanwhile we got the
Hawaiian Islands and we're a great power
in the Pacific and we're looking
hungrily at the mainland of Asia
Brooks Adams one of the four
conspirators said he who possesses
Shanxi province possesses the world
whereas Shanxi Province rose up in
northeast China or and Manchuria and it
was then the richest piece of territory
on earth it had iron it had coal it was
very very rich for the kind of
technology that they needed then the
Japanese had their eye on it United
States had their eye on it Germany was
even beginning to come and you know
slither around in the neighborhood so
that is Empire we are now launched as a
military power we had promised the
Filipinos that we would liberate them
from Spain and they could organize their
own government once we saw the value of
the possession of the Philippines
we went back cause we refused to remove
ourselves and we took over the
government of the Philippines that
caused a civil war in which something
like 100,000 Filipinos were killed and
women and children
we went slaughtering not long after a
major general charge of the Marine Corps
called Smedley Butler wrote a book and
he was coming down during the early part
of the century 1920s up to the 1930s and
he said I was essentially an enforcer
for the banks as commander of the Marine
Corps he said I was making Nicaragua
safe for Standard Oil I was making
Shanghai we invaded Shanghai safe for a
City National Bank or whatever the bank
was calling and he named all of the
great entities commercial entities that
he was working for even though he was
the United States government and he said
I was the hit man I was the enforcer for
these banks and these corporations he
said you know I operated it in three
continents
Al Capone only had three Chicago
districts this is not in the history
books and that's why I write these books
to remind people through a form of a
novel what was actually said and done
and what has been suppressed next call
for you is from Buffalo buffalo you're
on the air hi Buffalo again all right I
think we might have lost them the last
in the series before the Golden Age
Hollywood Hollywood this buddy asked me
what is the best said well Hollywood is
about what woodrow wilson and warren g
harding their presidencies i studied but
i also was a great deal about the
violent days of the movies one of the
figures that runs through the last two
or three eight novels is William
Randolph Hearst
who was a very important figure not only
did he invent tabloid journalism but if
there was no news he would invent it
which then puts the whole question what
is history on the table if the historian
goes back to old newspapers to
reconstruct an administration and that's
been faked
how's he to know what is history and
there the very end of the Golden Age
there's a whole meditation on the nature
of history is anything real so with
Empire with Hollywood what I'm doing is
I show the silent days the movies with
all of Chaplin and so on it's kind of
fun would you also see the influence of
first of government Woodrow Wilson on
Hollywood at the time of the first world
war he said a guy called George creel
out there and George creel was to
organize propaganda movies the Hun's
from hell stuff like that they did a lot
of propaganda Wilson appeared in at
least two movies as himself you know was
great some touches and injures thoughts
and something Washington realized the
importance of Hollywood and Hollywood
realize that Washington was very
interesting partner
they talked today about Hollywood and
you know as Otis or something new and
bizarre but it's been going on since
1914 that was symbiosis then I go into
Woodrow Wilson the first war that
disaster the League of Nations and
Warren Harding who was probably our
nicest president he really was a very
good man surrounded by very corrupt
people next call Yonkers New York
yes hello thanks for having me on the
air I wanted to ask mr. Vidal if you
could talk a little bit about the actual
process that you have to turn materials
that you have acquired in your
historical novels in and transform into
a narrative form the actual process by
which you compile the air be of the bulk
of the research material that you gather
and
transform and you know put it into a
creative narrative of well it does it
format it's it's a matter of reading and
I read you know I'll read a hundred two
hundred three hundred books sometimes
before I will start I have to own the
book so I can write in the margins and
as you read you begin to see
relationships between people that helps
you with your characters then you begin
to find things that have been omitted in
the official histories and you'd begin
to wonder why why has it been left out
why as General Smedley Butler forgotten
when he made such a startling gave such
a startling world view of our activities
it's a matter of lot taking a lot of
notes I was helped in this series
because I'm working with one family so I
know them and I and now I start with one
generation second generation third I've
got four generations in that so I'm at
home with a family I know I don't and
they are the fictional ones the real
ones are all interrelated which is a
curious thing that I found doing
American history that it's a very small
deck of cards that governs the United
States occasionally a new card is added
and Samoa cards are thrown out but it's
always pretty limited the players and
you see how from administration to
administration there they are first 40
years of our history of 50 year just
pretty much Virginians all who knew each
other except for the two atoms those who
came in and each got the heave-ho from
the Virginians I didn't want anybody
from Boston the white house you begin to
see these patterns and of course the
reading I mean I have the luxury of
taking all the best stuff from other
historians I just lift it and transform
it and
then I put my fictional characters
together with the real people and it's
not the reason for the fictional
characters is that they can observe and
have opinions which i's author must not
and i can't pretend that i know what
goes on in a rambling it's mine but i
can tell you what one of my invented
characters thinks of him and if there's
a contradiction in Lincoln I can have
another inventor cater no no no I don't
think that's what he meant at all so
this gives me the luxury to comment on
what I'm doing and then the historical
novel as I practice it is essentially
its history it's like it's like a
libretto and the fictional characters
are the music so you might say in a
sense these are sort of operas that the
music starts and these are the fictional
characters and then we go through the
familiar story Abraham Lincoln goes to
Ford's the editor and we know the plot
as we always know the plot of Julius
Caesar I eat it and then we have the
fictional characters observing what
happens with pity or with all when you
think of the small deck of cards in fact
you are an example of the
interconnectedness of the power in
America Oh My heavens yes a lot of that
is because my mother's family the Gores
were Anglo Irish from County Donegal who
came over in the 17th century well those
of us in the south who came from the
British Isles in the 17th 18th centuries
I think we're all related there's a few
of us you know that we intermarried not
only i I've never I've never said it
until now I don't think that in addition
to the gore family and my cousin it was
Albert Junior
of God I trembled sit but I'm going to
say this I get a lot of mail you know
from people who are relatives tickly
from the South because they know what
everybody's connections I am a fifth
cousin twice removed I don't know what
twice removed means except I think
by-election and defeat maybe is what is
meant of Jimmy Carter now you know it
you know the worst Jimmy Carter he had a
grandmother thing who was a Kay from
South Carolina and my grandmother who
really raised me mrs. Deeping gore was
born 9 a cake from a South Carolina
family and I'm totally Carter's this was
a favorite relative of Carter was the
Kay and she was certainly my favorite
one so Kennedy administration Jackie you
know I had the same stepfather
can you walk across her literally finish
your hand cause who was descended on his
mother's side so an uncle of Aaron Burr
and he had a painting of Theodosia
rather his friend of his had a painting
of Theodosius that I used to look at
when I was a child that's the daughter
by Burt Mexicans from San Diego its
Aloha mr. Ravi del I would have to say
that I hadn't really heard too much of
your speaking I've been aware of your
sort of stature in the literature
community and as a child of the baby
boomers and as a product of the
psychologically inadequate education
that we have unfortunately I always just
so totally surprised about the shocking
clarity of what you've been sort of
explaining the history of the age of
imperialism in the 20th century and
whatnot and I just had a quick question
regarding the relationship of William
Jennings Bryan that you were speaking of
earlier and the the sort of view how he
was supported by the green backers which
were willing to Lincoln's greenback
policy and that sort of a idealism and
also when Woodrow Wilson Willie Jennings
Bryan ran last I think in 1908 and that
would a Wilson of course in 12 and if
you of course won the election and how
Wilson the Democratic Party that was
sort of manipulated by Wall Street
they passed the Federal Reserve how that
sort of went against everything that
William Jennings Bryan thought and
perhaps in a lust for wanted victory it
seems as if the the Democratic Party in
1912 sold themselves out like the
Republicans did after the post-civil war
era thanks a lot to work with there
thank you for the that's very well said
he's quite right the Democratic Party
then became part of the corporate party
along with the Republican Party and it
was Wilson's election that did it Wilson
himself might not have gone that line
but Lee Wilson wasn't it fell for
imperialism Wilson was very divided
about World War two and that's where he
had my grandfather parted my grandfather
had helped elect in fact he was in
charge of the 1912 campaign out of
Chicago and they didn't get on but
Wilson did say not to him but somebody
else rather wistfully said I wanted to
be a domestic president and Here I am a
war president and I am he was in favor
of the war and he said I know at the end
of this war those great entities that I
have fought the Trust's the banks will
own the United States for this war is
over which is pretty much what happened
I proposed the caller from San Diego on
would rule on William Jennings Bryan
Bryan demonstrated his anti-imperialism
when Wilson got us into the war Bryan
was his secretary of state and Bryan
resigned I have not known any man of
state ever to resign a post so high
because of a disagreement over policy
but the populist and then the true
Americans I like to think of it did not
want Foreign Wars they saw no point why
on earth should we be disturbed by the
Kaiser so he wanted to have a fight with
France let him ever fight with France
it's none of our business
and he spoke to be a buffoon Brian
because of the Monkey Trial in Tennessee
he was no fool he was a man of principle
he had a great speech explaining his
last speech at a convention he said no
matter of my faults as a man and as a
politician I have kept the faith in
these many events over these years of
American history that youth chronicled
is there one that you really wish you
could have been at in person no first of
all I did time in a time machine I don't
want to go anywhere where there's no
anaesthetic you could just forget it I
think we would be very uncomfortable in
any of those past places the one volume
I would like to have written that I
didn't and it's now far too late because
I can't do this or research anymore but
I missed out on a Mexican War I surely
should have done Henry Clay and Franklin
Pierce was fascinating president the
most overtly naked ly ambitious he picks
a war with Mexico in order to grab
California and they hold southwest of
the United States that's the fascinating
time and Lincoln was a young politician
opposed to the war but then went along
with it and out of it came of course
Jefferson Davis and mrs. grant
it was probably our greatest prose
writer his memoirs are a masterpiece
welcome penniless knight dying of cancer
he lost all of his money in one of the
crashes at Wall Street prepared every
cent was gone so and he was leaving
Julia his wife with no money so he makes
a deal with Mark Twain who was also a
publisher and paid him an enormous
advance and as he died he I think he
finished the book one day got the money
for his wife the next and died
well the popular at the time oh yes some
two volumes and in due course it was
disdained by literary people because he
was known to have been a pretty bad
president but he was very great general
what nobody knew and it was Gertrude
Stein I think first pointed it out
he wrote the best American prose I'm he
had a grandeur writers like Henry James
but for the plain style it was perfect
that was what West Point did you had to
be clear when you sent an order send the
second battalion to such-and-such a hill
you had to be precise you couldn't be
windy and it's a beautifully tight
austere rather the way of a rather like
Judas Caesars except Caesars to self
servings these are is nothing but trying
to trying to convince you it was
Montaigne said about how maddening
Caesar is and it writes about his doings
in the Gallic Wars we all want to know
how how he was such a great general and
all it wants to do is convince us what a
great engineer he was he wastes pages
after pages on how he built a bridge or
a river
grant doesn't do that he stays with a
subject Philadelphia next hello it's a
great pleasure from em great admirer of
your works mr. Badal and of you and
personally I would like to speak about
Lincoln
you have aptly said that he is the
tragic figure of American political
history I wonder if you could expand on
your opinion of the impact of his
personality both as a president and as
an American icon in the context of your
broader themes of empire and militarism
and secondly someplace else you refer to
the American civil wars our
Peloponnesian War which i think is
really a very brilliant analogy and I
wish you could expand on that again it's
great pleasure to hear you thank you
well Lincoln is a mysterious of the
presidents and III there is an error is
the kind of megalomania about him in
when he was 29 and he was a legislator
in Springfield he gave a speech to the
young men's Lyceum I think school and it
was really on power and presidential
power and I don't know by heart I can
give you a little bit of paraphrase that
he said about the man of great ambition
will not be content with simply
occupying the presidential chair first
occupied by Washington he will not want
to be a successor that will not suit him
nor will it suit anyone who is of the
race of the lion and the Eagle such a
man will be born and he will seek
another field and to prevail he could
free all the slaves and enslave all free
men now this is Shakespeare this is
Richard the third warning us against
himself and he's 29 when he gives it and
he goes on and it takes a very hard line
because he and he said all along I have
no power to free the slaves there is
nothing in the presidential powers
there's nothing in Congress's power
property is property in Venice slavery
is a shameful business but I can do
nothing then the South being suspicious
of him in the new Republican Party
full of booze and Walter Scott decided
to start succeeding and he did his best
to try to hold him back but they were
going anyway they saw the North
intervening in their affairs and he said
finally as they finally all went he
declared war and it was on a curious
issue that our history books teaches it
was two previous layers civil war while
the slaves had nothing to do with it
Lincoln cooked up something that was
only in his own brain that it was to
preserve the Union and he was he was
always always eloquent but he said I
some went to the Union to break other
others do not people differ but I have
an oath sworn in heaven to preserve
protect and defend the United States of
America you will not go I will not
acknowledge that you have left he would
never say the Confederate States of
America
he never acknowledged that there was any
entity but one United States
he was the unionists he was not an
abolitionist right or wrong is something
else again I I treat him in a
sympathetically in a balanced way and
sometimes rather critically what he did
now I think much of his famous
melancholy and so on was his knowledge
that what he had done was reflective of
that speech he gave the young man at 29
he had transformed the United States
from a rather loose Federation of states
into a tight union in which hundreds of
thousands of young men had died and
cities and cultures were wrecked and he
was had created a bloodbath
he also made the United States the most
formidable military power in the world
and I always felt and indeed the code of
my view that Lincoln there I'll read you
the last paragraph
I think he knew perfectly well what he
had done and I think well see what I
said here
John Hay is in Paris and he was Lincoln
secretary and they're comparing Lincoln
to Bismarck Bismarck at the same time
was doing to the German States exact
same time who were independent that
Lincoln was doing to the American state
and I think said mr. Schuyler to the
princess we have here a subject Lincoln
and Bismarck and new countries for old
and he says well it will be interesting
to see how mr. Bismarck ends his career
says hey who was now more than ever
convinced that Lincoln in some
mysterious fashion had willed his own
murder as a form of atonement for the
great and terrible thing that he had
done by giving so bloody and absolute a
rebirth to his nation our next question
is also about Lincoln it from Sacramento
you're on the air
good afternoon mr. Vidal um I have a
quote from I don't know where the quote
comes from it says it's from Abe Lincoln
I see in the near future a crisis
approaching that unnerves me and causes
me to tremble for the safety of my
country corporations have been enthroned
in an era of corruption and high places
will follow and the money power of the
country will endeavor to prolong its
reign by working upon the prejudices of
the people until all wealth is
aggregated in a few hands and the
Republic is destroyed could you tell me
where this comes from
well it's legion alright and it was I
can't tell you I forgotten do you do you
no collar are you still cooking sourcing
newspaper sound in a newspaper yeah well
it's it's
the Lincoln style is unmistakable - that
is Lincoln it would have been towards
the end and it probably would have been
in a letter it was never in a speech but
he would he would occasionally give
heartfelt letters to correspondence or
to little newspapers around the country
and that was his way of addressing the
people and subjects that would not he
couldn't do in the State of the Union
that sounds like one of his meditations
which turned out to be prophetic in your
reflection on the role of historical
fiction in your newest book the Golden
Age you tell a story about the reaction
by the Lincoln files the Lincoln Brigade
yes will you tell that story which one I
got so many stir well the one is
actually about your speculation that he
dosed himself
oh well Lincoln told Herndon who was for
17 years his law partner in Springfield
and they shared the same office and it
was the only friend I think Lincoln ever
had he had well in maturity before that
there was Joshua speed but Herndon I
didn't know if he's a friend but the two
men in an office two lawyers practicing
together Herndon is the best all we have
for 17 years of Lincoln's life and if
you and some people try to rule him out
because he tells things that are
inconvenient Lincoln told him how he got
syphilis when he was in his late 20s and
he'd gone to a doctor in Cincinnati
since he'd be gone to anybody in
Springfield
it would have been everybody would know
and as he said he clung to him he
couldn't get rid of syphilis so he
finally was cured if you ever are with
mercury which is very dangerous stuff to
take and it brings on all sorts of
mental and physical debilities Lincoln
was very hard at times and it conforms I
have a dr. Hirsh Warren I think he is
who writes me occasion and he's doing a
study of Lincoln syphilis rugged with
treatment for it which is mercury did he
have mercury poisoning and they are
great many of his symptoms the
melancholy and they suddenly be talking
to him and he just stare off into space
and not hear you it easiest nightmare is
he would wake up screaming in the night
and the White House and there's a good
case to be made that he indeed he had
mercury poisoning but at one point they
he took something called blue well blue
pills a purge for constipation which had
mercury in it also and finally he's
getting worried about because he knows
something is going wrong so he taught
some talk about he figures out he'll
stop taking these purges and he did and
he became pretty healthy again well all
of this was quite well the Lincoln
Brigade a great man has syphilis with a
girl you know high up maggoty said one
greatest ours is a maggoty story well
it's an essential story and it has to do
with the health and mind of the
president forgetting sex life
oh I cover it up and that's what they do
and one of the best things results of my
Lincoln which was has been a formatively
successful with the public and now with
many scholars I'm really giving it to
the Lincoln Brigade we'll keep trying to
falsify him far more to the point and
that is that Lincoln I am convinced to
the day he went to Ford's Theater still
wanted to colonize the freed slaves at
the South in Central America he'd
already got hold of some land down there
which is now you're near Nicaragua or
over Inlet and Liberia
he said he wanted to do that in his
first State of the Union and then he
sort of dropped it in public and in due
course he's freed the slaves in the
south during the war but not the ones in
the north who firmly from the border
state which he could have done and he
didn't do that because he needed the
white out there so basically this was
his plan because he kept saying he
rationalizes he said these are three
million people who have been held in
terrible
slavery they are without education there
without skills and so on and he got a
bunch of free men free black men from
New York to try to persuade their
cousins in the south to go to Liberia I
think one of them said delaying it I
have all this of the boys why do you
think they can't support themselves when
they have supported themselves and their
masters in considerable luxury for the
last 200 years leading that much an
answer to that or and finally they said
well you know this is our country we've
been here as long as you have we see no
reason that we should go off to the
jungles of Africa now the latest word
from the Lincoln Brigade
is that Lincoln did have the notion but
gave it up after his first year in
office golus ignores John Hay his young
Secretary's diary when he writes his
colleague Nicolay
he said the ancient is it was their code
name for the ancient I think this is
August 1864 I think has given up his air
brain notion to ship all the slaves out
of the south at last he's been convinced
by something had gone wrong then general
Ben Butler and his memoir unsavory
figure but he says that Lincoln before
had brought up the subject again in the
early spring before Ford's Theatre of 65
about colonizing them both swear
so one very clever historian came up
with the fact that secretary Stanton and
Victor Ward said no general officer can
come to town without permission during a
coup I think and Butler couldn't have
been in Washington which my answer is
nobody told general Butler what to do if
he wanted to come he came and if we
could had said that too and why not now
this is the extent to which in the age
of Martin Luther King the white
historians have gone out of their minds
trying to readjust history and this is
this has been one of the great Spurs for
me to write these books I can't bear the
falsifications of the data the data is
pretty clear they have to twist
themselves into knots and history so it
has finally come to this that if you
wanted the real truth of the situation
was turned to a novel and he was reject
the court historians who were there to
falsify take one last question before a
brief break and it'll be from Chicago
you're on the air
yes mr. Badal an honor sir I think I
have there were so many questions to ask
but here's the one I'm going to ask and
it's a what-if question if burr had
remained politically viable after the
duel or if Hamilton had not died because
of their military capabilities do you
believe the early course of the war of
1812 might have been different for
example could we have acquired Canada
etc well as you know if you read me on
the subjects whenever in doubt we invade
Canada at the time of the Revolution
when the British occupied I think they'd
already occupied New York and
Philadelphia first thing General
Washington does at Lexington is send
Benedict Arnold and Erin Byrd up to
Canada to Montreal to Quebec rally to
conquer Canada they failed at the time
of the war of 1812 one of the first
moves made was to invade Canada this is
when the British were burning down the
White House and they taken Washington
we didn't care about that we want to
Canada I think had Burr and Hamilton not
ins not one dead in the other under a
cloud I think we would have been more
militaristic burr always I'll tell you
who drove these two men remember they're
both five foot four or five was Napoleon
Bonaparte in 1800 when Burr became vice
president Napoleon was you know about to
be Emperor France and going to conquer
Europe both Hamilton and burr had their
eye on Mexico and where the Spanish work
and there's Mexicans didn't like Spanish
and Hamilton was dealing with one group
of indigenous Mexicans for want of a
better word to get the Spanish out and
Bert was also maneuvering to make
himself emperor of Mexico after he
ceased to be vice-president was under a
murder charge up in New York so he goes
down to Mississippi with a little army
and all prepared to invade Mexico and
take over gets a lot of help morale help
certainly from Jackson Andrew Jackson
and Henry Clay
this was the bum rap the Jefferson
President Jefferson put on buries that
burr wants to separate the western
states from the eastern he didn't he
wanted to go down Mississippi go to New
Orleans go over to Mexico and make
himself Emperor so Jefferson arrested
him for treason which he had not
committed and it was a bum rap and
everybody knew and he was exonerated but
your what if question yes I I think that
had burger on to be president which was
the original arrangement with Jefferson
no Jefferson was a very it a noble but
sly and devious man
I must say Richard M Nixon who had the
most wonderful unconscious mind says in
six crises General Eisenhower was a far
more sly and devious man and people
suspected and I mean that in the best
sense of those words I agree with our
caller here that eighteen war of 1812
might have ended with an invasion of
Mexico and of Canada our conversation
with forever dollars just half way over
we're going to take a break of about
five minutes in length during that we'll
show you some upcoming programming here
on book TV on c-span two and then we'll
be back for second 90 minutes of
in-depth conversations with gore Vidal
in just a moment both TVs live in depth
with the gore Vidal continues I love you
Ronnie is a new book by former First
Lady Nancy Reagan it's comprised of
letters her husband former President
Ronald Reagan wrote to her over the
years and her reflections on the letters
the book is number three on this week's
New York Times bestseller list last week
mrs. Reagan signed copies of the book of
the Ronald Reagan Presidential Library
in Simi Valley California you can see
that event following our live in-depth
with gore Vidal today at about 3 p.m.
and later tonight at 9:30 Eastern here
on book TV only on c-span - this is a
new collection of essays called the best
American science writing 2000 and next
Sunday on book TV will feature a panel
discussion with contributors to this
book including Stephen Jay Gould on the
scientist discredited by Darwin madly
and cheer on the fashion sense of
prehistoric humans and Oliver Sacks on
how his family introduced him to science
a panel also includes the books editor
James Glick on the whole field of
science writing the best American
science writing 2000 next Sunday at noon
and again at midnight the southern
festival of books takes place in
Nashville
October 13th 14th and 15th southern
writers will gather to take part in book
signings and pal
questions and book TV will bring you
live coverage of the festival Saturday
October 14th here on c-span 2 here's a
list of the best-selling non-fiction
books from the conservative book club at
number one sellout by David shippers it
examines the impeachment proceedings
against President Clinton next the
triumph of Liberty Jim Powell's
collection of stories about people who
have contributed to America's fight for
liberty Thomas Jefferson Elizabeth Cady
Stanton Cicero and others at number
three the long march by Roger Kimball
looks at the effect of the 1960s
cultural revolution on America book TV
is featuring mr. Kimball's what this
weekend the world according to Gore has
a critical examination of Vice President
Al Gore as he runs for president by
nationally syndicated columnist Deborah
Saunders it's at number four next is
from dawn to decadence by cultural
critic and historian Jacques farzam it's
a look at Western cultural life from the
16th century to the present year of the
rat Hal Bill Clinton compromised us
security for Chinese cash is by Edward
Timberlake and William Triplett it's
number six 7th is the home schoolers
guide to portfolios and transcripts by
Loretta Heuer at number 8 the
irrepressible rothbard by Llewellyn
Rockwell what is a man by historian and
commentator waller Newell uses writings
from Shakespeare Plato and the Bible to
define masculinity and finally number 10
the average family's guide to financial
freedom by a husband and wife team Bill
and Mary Chui the conservative book club
focuses on politics religion history and
current events from a conservative point
of view the club was founded in 1964 and
currently has 70,000 members for more
information call 1 888 get book
what do you like to read well I love
poetry and I love literature from all
over the world right now I'm reading The
Unbearable Lightness of being by Milan
Kundera and it's an amazing book it's so
weird because he is check and I'm
originally from southern Africa but the
characters they just they're so great
it's like I can relate to some of the
characters in the book I can relate to
exactly what is going on in the book and
what he's talking about
it's just things that we've all probably
thought at some point in our lives but
it's not you know been written down it's
not being articulated and when you're
reading it you're like oh my gosh
this is makes so much sense so that's
what I'm reading right now give me an
example of one of those things that you
find so interesting okay what I find so
interesting in this particular book
there's a passage where he's talking
about when you are an expatriate because
these characters are Czechs living in
Switzerland and he says something about
when these characters do not have a
safety net you don't have the the
comfort of having your friend your
family they're all your friends and
speaking the st. the language that you
were born you know into that culture
you're born into so you don't have that
safety net and at some some times I have
felt that way because I'm an expected to
this country so it just makes so much
sense and I really love the book but I
also love children's book and The BFG is
my favorite book of all time by Roald
Dahl so I love that book um history
books history of Venice by Norwich on
his arm there's a Hitler history book by
Lucas I like in my favorite is all the
President's Men by woodwork members why
do you like that book because the movie
was based on it and I like to movie
what should you like better the book of
the movie um the book just ten times
better
told a lot of stuff they left out in the
movie was really good um gosh it just
that was my favor throughout the fall
book fairs and festivals we'll be
bringing together authors publishers and
readers and here's a look at some of the
events coming up the 25th annual Deep
South writing conference gets underway
October 10th it takes place on the
university of Louisiana's campus at
lafayette nashville tennessee hosts the
12th annual southern festival of books
the three-day event includes readings
panel discussions and signings by
authors from around the world in
November the Buckeye Book Fair happens
on the 4th and Wooster Ohio it'll
highlight new releases written by
Ohioans and books on topics relating to
the state the military history book fair
takes place in Pigeon Forge Tennessee
from November 10th to the 12th it's part
of the town's 15 day event honoring
America's veterans also in November the
kentucky book fair on the 18th and
frankfort on the campus of kentucky
state university and on the first
weekend of December of the san
bernardino latino book and family
festival gets underway with educational
workshops book signings and poetry
readings if you'd like more information
about these fairs and festivals go to
our website book TV org there you'll
find an expanded festival list and hot
links to festival websites and please
let us know about book fairs and
festivals in your area and we'll add
them to our website list write to us at
book TV on c-span
- 400 North Capitol Street Northwest
suite 650 Washington DC - 0 0 0 1
gore Vidal joins us for this month's
in-depth program a three-hour
conversation which we are halfway
through and right now has a brand new
book out which is called the Golden Age
it is the seventh and final in a series
of American history told in a historical
novel and also a play that has been
revived on Broadway a few writers
looking at your life right now are
suggesting that urine or something of a
golden age yourself does it feel like it
no 75 is not a golden age it has certain
elements of lead particularly the knees
are you beginning to think about legacy
are you you want to be in my will is
that angle yeah look I just brought a
codicil with me I'm about preserving
what's important to you beyond the works
that have been published do you think
about that sue thing as Groucho Marx
once so wisely said how he would be
remembered he said what has posterity
ever done for me that's my view of the
future future doesn't exist because it's
not there yet well it's there I won't
exist so we go our separate ways you've
I would suspect describing your writing
place surrounded by your books collected
quite a number of them over the years is
that of interest you to have them
preserved as a collection so that others
may see your work well others are
interested I mean universities and so on
my papers are transferring from one
University to Harvard to the Houghton
library and I think that's yes I do i I
do think that for instance
correspondence I have letters from
everybody that I've kept everything for
seventy years so it will all be in one
place ah yeah I like that idea
even though I won't be around but for
historians and I think more of them than
anybody else yes
part of this program that's very
important are your telephone calls and
next is one from Massapequa New York and
you are welcome to this conversation
with Corbett all yes hi I'm reading
these questions so be a little more
accurate the first one is what caused or
prompted you to write light from Gaza
and just as a comment it the book
doesn't leave the Christian faithful
with much awe about the centerpiece
object i either seen porn on of their
face
thanks again same question it's in your
work you didn't hear word you know you
are not plugged in I'm going to ask our
technician to plug you in while I repeat
the qualification thanks very much the
the question is about the book live from
Golgotha and wanted to know what
prompted you and her observation was
that it doesn't leave those of the
Christian faced with much about the
centerpiece event well I it is after all
a satiric work on the founder of
christianity who was of course not jesus
with saint paul and it has a theology
and it is not bad and it's basically an
tied paul line that he reinvented jesus
who intended himself only for the jews
as a possible Jewish Messiah and Paul
wanted to make him international for
everybody and that was a distortion of
the Christian original Christian message
to the extent that we understand it at
all
so I've wrote a comedy about it which I
thought is the subject deserve I myself
have become seriously
well I wouldn't say agnostic I think I'm
closer to atheist but I love Christian
quarreling and I've wrote a book called
Julian about Julian the apostate 4th
century Emperor who tried to stop
Christianity in his tracks and that was
favorable to the Emperor Julian and not
so favorable to the bishops that he went
to war against I think what we're going
to do I'm your technology is not quite
when I a belief got a speaker in here
you knows you're just not plugged in we
didn't do that after our break so we'll
have to listen to the next call on
speaker and make sure you can hear Las
Vegas you are on the air welcome we
don't here to speaker out here Las Vegas
go ahead please Last Vegas go ahead hi
Susan and hi mr. Badal I'm a great
admirer of yours especially because of
your frankness with which you express
yourself
I enjoyed your monograms you did for our
Dhoni and press about the American
presidency so but I had a couple of
questions first what American presidents
if any do you admire did you admire and
would you say a few words about Norm
Tomsky who most of whose books I have
and whom I also admire very much thank
you thank you well of admirable
presidents it's very hard to separate
them from the times in which they lived
some very marvelous men have been
forgotten because they were not in
interesting times I would say that well
John Quincy Adams I suppose he will he
last served only one term which is not
successful but I quoted from him earlier
as an anti-imperialist he also when he
was Secretary of State he wrote the
Monroe Doctrine which has President
Monroe's name but it was his work
he was the first person perhaps the last
American president to understand foreign
affairs and what America's role should
be which was do business with everybody
have no special friends no special
enemies no prejudices and certainly not
be the world's policeman I suppose JQ
Adams Noam Chomsky and I are allies we
do the same sort of thing that often
were the same sort of audiences we did a
an anti Gulf War a half hour discussion
for some independent at the time
television people know one or two of us
with an interlocutor no one would put it
on the air not even at four o'clock on a
Sunday morning in San Francisco would
they put it on air I've never seen such
fear across the land I wish you'd called
us we would have air ducts were you
around at the time of the Gulf War
uniform but I think I think we must have
because the guy who produced it
certainly was very busy with it and we
had a good team from ABC who did it for
nothing you know just pro bono publico
Chomsky and I of course we have the same
enemies by your enemies what the
one-one-one is celebrated largely the
New York Times and his funny story of
Chomsky he went to the dentist and
Dennis said John your teeth are all
right but you got to stop grinding them
he said they don't grind my teeth
he said well you do it was the namma was
worn off well I don't so mrs. Johnson
was only hazardous but well he sleeps
does he graduates teased he said no miss
resident well they both got terribly
interested when did it happen well they
finally found out in the morning while
having coffee and she might be out of
the room he would start to read the New
York Times as his teeth with her
mine grind - and I read that paper
particularly the things they do - that
scientists at Los Alamos or their
invention of the whitewater plot - bad
paper New Orleans next a Barbie doll yes
I love your books I keep rereading the
matter-of-fact and one of the things
that keeps that strikes me is um that
your your work changes over the years I
mean I mean not my interpretation of
your work changes over the years for
example Messiah was that kind of book
for me it meant different things to me
as different events took place in the
country but one the thing I'm interested
now is is Lincoln I'm rereading Lincoln
and one of the things I wanted to know
now that such Dutch came out is there
any difference other than that ideology
between your method and Morrises Edmund
Morris's okay thanks for the call
actually would you speak a bit about
Messiah before we return to you know
Messiah came out I had a period after
the city in the pillar when the New York
Times Book Review Orville Prescott and
he was very powerful he did about five
daily reviews a week told my publisher
that not only would he never review a
book by me but he'd never read one so I
published seven books that were never
reviewed in the daily New York Times or
by time or by Newsweek this was a
blackout all because I had said in the
city in the pillar about the normality
of a relation between two all-american
boys and I was the war novelist etc who
was pronouncing that upon this heresy
the seventh of the books that were not
reviewed by the New York Times was
Messire
and it came out invisibly because you
get no press particularly if the Times
will not look at it or the night news
magazines
but something odd happened it's about a
man who sort of says says he's a messiah
or people say he is and his message is
that death is no thing therefore nothing
can not be a bad thing and in selling
that it becomes a sort of cult which
finally ends a lot of it's been lifted
from movies so lien green stole a
wonderful piece of it where people go to
commit suicide
to these comforting places new lie and
look at a screen and you see movies or
whatever well the book became a cult
book and in no time at all they just
more and more people started to read it
and handed around and I was fascinated
by the diversity of those who were drawn
to this thing on another level it showed
how easily through television that you
could create a religion how quickly it
took Christianity centuries to take over
Europe and he does his men two or three
years into the end of course they want
him to commit suicide as he said
encouraged others to do and he doesn't
want to so they have to kill him and
pretended he killed himself
as death is no thing and how Wyatt
College to this day is selling and our
Gleason has not not a great seller but
it has them has its devotees
if television can so quickly create
messiahs why have we not seen them in
the television age well we do we see
their spokespersons the Jerry Falwell ro
Roberts Billy Graham they're doing
they're making a lot of money out of
being professional prophets it is such
as now that you've asked that question
that's interesting when I this hasn't
occurred me why somebody hasn't used it
to start a new religion Oh Scientology I
don't know if they've used television
but they've certainly made themselves
into
religion from a book by a
science-fiction writer of the 50s we had
the same publisher for Messiah that l
ron hubbard had for Dianetics I guess
that's the case but not to UV you'd have
to have a charismatic type so far they
wrap themselves in Jesus or sing my way
on television
Flanders New Jersey or next yes mr.
Badal an honor sir two questions first
what you see the trajectory of the novel
being in the next century and second can
any amount of pleading on my behalf
convince you to write a nickel in a
series well plead some more I might go
back to 1846 but I don't see myself
doing the Kennedy years or anything
closer because if I did it having been
involved I would probably have to do
another memoir to cover it which might
be the way of doing it and I might yet
yet do that the novel is the going sort
of strange patch it's become Academy
sized most of the writers and certainly
practically all the reviewers seem to be
English teachers I don't think this is
necessarily a good thing you can make
books out of books writers have always
done it or been inclined to do it but
anterior to literature is something
called life and if you haven't had a
life it is a bit of a really involved
one even it's just simply an inner life
sitting by a pond and New England you're
not going to be very interesting and
that to me is a problem that the writer
is now working particularly ones were
school teachers in university that's a
little experience of the world and
there's so much they're shut out Mary
McCarthy was wonderful on this she made
a list of all the things that a novelist
may not do a novelist who's considered
serious
you can't have a sunset you can't have
an election you can't have a really good
dinner party you can't have and she just
lays this list of all the things which
is made classic fiction great
I've been carefully put away oh no that
would be corny over we don't know enough
God likes it have a president in the
book how can you read about everyone
what are you some sort of statuses you
don't know any presidents they pride
themselves on the fact that they go to
school they stay in school they get
tenure and some may have a real talent
for writing but there isn't see there it
must be a little spark which is known as
life to set you going I had a fairly
interesting life and certainly three
years of the army gave me an awful lot
to write about so the trajectory I don't
think is very promising people who want
narratives and want to be amused by
stories are now videocassette I find
something very odd going wrong but
people who use computers now maybe it's
the people or maybe it's just my
inability to understand but I think the
prose is flattening out I can tell
computer prose very often out
particularly when the same paragraph
occurs three times the two pages and I
know it's a computer on a blink it'll be
interesting to see what happens but I
think that the only form of prose that
is going to last is the essay people
need that that is it's short it's one
man's voice making connection of another
man's person's eyes it is you're
suddenly we've got Montaigne from a 500
years ago and he's talking to you is
over you're in the room and you can
respond to them it's really the kinetic
energy is so great between the great
essays and the readers well thinking
about this we should tell our audience
that a new collection of your essays is
scheduled for the spring of spring yes
there reissuing United States which
Random House my last publisher the
second I left them to go to
they pulp that they just got rid of it
and first as my collected essays over
fifty years that will be out with EE in
the spring and a new volume of of essays
called the last Empire and that should
do it
do you think that should do it oh I go
on writing of course but this is a
pretty big book of essays would be some
time before I have another volume we
talked to submitted about editors over
the years and how you use editors I had
much to do with him not got it very nice
with it Doubleday it was actually
interested in books most of them are
interested in marketing now and their
eyes glaze over at the floor of
literature he likes it is dedicated to
it
I had one very fatherly one Nicolas
Raiden at EP Dutton when I was 1920 and
Dutton published about seven novels ten
novels it ending with Messiah and he was
a very nice white Russian and he was a
very good editor and no problem I'm not
edited I'm copy edited to go over to
make sure that and I have no dangling
participles but I don't get help for
anything I've completed the work by the
time I give it to the publisher and a
wonderful man at little brown where I
was probably happiest and left them like
a fool they did Julian and they did
Washington DC admire a breckenridge and
we had a successful time
Random House was not so pleasant and
Doubleday is well we're on the subject
of how we write in the mechanics when
you described grants writing as West
Point in what about your own how would
you describe your writing well I had
different different voices I'm a mimic
and I can mimic are used to look when
younger and more alert
and also being a dramatist I can make
scenes and people actually talk in
different voices which conform with
whatever their characters are if I'm
comparison a ting a Roman Emperor I will
have one style for Julian Myra
Breckinridge has a style never before
heard or seen on this earth she is
furious terrible clamor in my head as I
was putting her down so there are
different styles cyclin we should have a
cover for the paperback of Myra
Breckinridge as we take our next
telephone call and it is from Seattle
hello mr. Vidal I really appreciate your
books and I was wondering if you'd
comment on the use of covert activity
from the time of birth through Lincoln
and now that we're spending 30 billion
dollars on covert activity actually
controls our foreign affairs how do you
I mean all the people are interested in
spies but most people don't believe that
are not interested in really knowing
what's going on with her CIA in this
country well I deplore our secret
government the CIA is I deplore the Los
Angeles Police Department which used to
have a foreign policy and they were
against enemies with hit na war which I
was the whole country is becoming a
police state here's a statistic that I
saw on a front page of USA Today not a
week ago there are six million people in
prison or in what they call in
correction
I suppose that's parole or reforms
causes of it six million people that's
3% to the adult population no other
country has ever imprisoned so many of
its own people proportionately as we
have done what is this about
the harassment of Americans have you
taken a trip by plane lately I have to
travel with a passport in my pocket in
my own country
now enhance they have an enemy with it
make sure why do you have to have an ID
with a picture don't if I'm a terrorist
I'm going to have a fake one you fool
this harassment it never lets have we
now have in New York there is a every
taxi cab bike a lap this is a eateth
Wharton well you know a government that
does not care enough about us to give us
a National Health Service which other
countries have is terribly worried that
we may go through the windshield
this constant harassment of the people
and one day I think they're going to
rise up and tear this damn thing to
pieces would that I were young and it
was spring and very heaven to be their
hometown next Washington DC mr. Badal
what a pleasure and a privilege my
favorite of yours was Lincoln and I
picked it up for the first time 10 years
ago having never paid too much attention
to historical fiction I then embarked on
a reading campaign over the course of
five years Sandburg bruce catton
it just brought history alive for me in
a way that no one else had and indeed
you will live on these books that I'm
standing in my apartment looking at now
my son will inherit and of course his
children will and hopefully from it will
come as a historian that you so admire
so I have a question I've noticed an
attitude of disrespect that's being
embraced by scholars by teachers by
schools for the accomplishments of our
forefathers not just our politicians our
leaders but our business leaders in
general in this country many people feel
this ties in with the changing
demographics of this country how do you
feel I don't I wouldn't use the word
disrespect
I think analysis and it's not brilliant
analysis because
the people in our universities are
rather timid and conform for a lot of
reasons but I think that many people are
asking questions why have we come to the
point that I had to carry a passport in
the United States so that I have ID with
a picture over the years attempts have
been made for us to have it cards of
identity which fascist states require
and bonaparte style democracy's also
require like Italy in France this is
alien to the American tradition and yet
now they've got it
I don't know how a diners club with a
picture on it is identification of any
kind but in a way that's what they want
the constant intrusion they're getting
the hold of your social security number
what they're doing on the internet and
buying things and they have a records
they keep their own records on just
about everybody I think if there is
disrespect for that I think that's good
and if there is curiosity about how we
got into this state most people think
the CIA was always there it wasn't it
was founded in 48 47 48 it's totally
illegal unconstitutional I should say it
does not submit its its accounts to
Congress as the Constitution required
lately they have seemed to be conforming
to the law but I rather doubt it it's
totally a rogue out there we have so
many secret services that we don't know
anything about them and we have so many
activities going on abroad that we will
never know anything about because
they're kept obscure from us you
remember you know David Hume said in
1745 and he said how are the many who
are many and so powerful and thus
powerful controlled by the few who are
few and less powerful he said it is done
through opinion and opinion is formed by
the schools and the churches and the
broadsheets which is what they
all newspapers them he who controls
religion who controls education and the
press the class that does will create in
the opinion that it wants to do anything
that it wants if it's in England they
want to war with France opinion will go
against the French I have been reading
American opinion all my life I have been
reading I have never read a story and
the American press that was favorable to
any other Society we are constantly
bad-mouthing every other country on
earth and we're the greatest we're the
greatest really everybody envies us
we're so good Sweden yes they have
better education better health service
better daycare centers for working
mothers but they're all alcoholics and
they kill themselves as though because
you have good health and good education
you'll be so bored with your life that
you were want to commit suicide and get
drunk
this constant grip torture of
misinformation has really skilled the
entire country no one knows what to
think about anything I think a great
many people have just pulled out they
just ignore the constant propaganda yes
we do get a lot of fairly true
information but who can wade through it
it comes at us in such avalanches
changing times Palm Springs California
for gore Vidal thank you for c-span and
thank you for this interview with mr.
Vidal my name is Joanna and I met you
call I had the great fortune of meeting
you in Rome and also to have lunch with
you in Ravello together with my friend
Joan we would use mind and mass dynamics
for an encounter with you in the Piazza
del Ponte on I even wrote anonymous note
saying gore Vidal you are so beautiful
that was 15 years ago now I would like
to say to you mr. Vidal you are too
beautiful Thank You mr. Vidal thank you
I haven't received a compliment like
that in at least 15 years Milwaukee
mr. Vidal um I work for a radio station
and I'm I'm very protective of people's
trust of daily journalism whether
broadcasting or newspapers I remember
seeing a movie
25 years ago called Network in which he
warned patty Trotsky warned us of
messengers would come and say don't
trust the mass media trust me and and he
would lead them in the direction plus
inform them at the same time and are we
getting closer to an age of that where
we have people who call themselves the
messengers the mass media is not
reporting this but I'm the one that's
telling you this inside information and
here's the direction that our government
and society should be headed is there
something new or is this always happen
in various forms in American history
well governments generally mislead us
and then again messengers generally have
the wrong message so that there is no
generality that we can make out of this
situation I think the opinion in the
sense that David Hume used it is
constant and is generally self-serving
in this case with the government the
United States there are messengers there
are voices that are telling the truth
that are useful however everything that
a government can do to silence Noam
Chomsky or me that's an example they
will do
I talked to Chomsky I was up at Harvard
giving a lecture and they had fliers all
around the Harvard Yard saying where I
was would be speaking what time about
several hundred them within 30 minutes
they'd all been torn down there was no
mention that I was there and the Harvard
Crimson no message and they brought some
papers I drew two or three thousand
people that was the day I saw Chomsky
and he said explain he said really do
that to me too
I said okay and it's all across the
country this happens because opinion
does not want us to be heard I said okay
how is it that we draw one to three
thousand people how do they know we're
there
and Jeff Chomsky said I think it's
mystical I don't know if there is some
sort of underground out there that knows
when something interesting is
to happen so that's how we messengers
get around caller we are drawn by the
underground the underground has pulled
us into their orbit so it's tearing down
the Flyers at that time I should think
what does call neoconservatives
were the most motivated next call Idaho
Falls
that's an Idaho go ahead please uh oh I
was interested by your comment where you
mentioned that the American history has
been dealt from a very small deck the
Adams family seems to be part of this
deck which is distinct from your
connections I and you talked about
Brooks Adams I guess I was interested if
you could elaborate a little more on
this person he's the one Adams
member of the Adams clan that I have a
lot of trouble finding out anything
about because very good biography of
Brooks Adams I have a copy of it don't
ask me the author's name I'm at that
stage of my in the springtime of my
senility I'm beginning to lose names
right and left but Brooks Adams there is
a good biography I mean there's a great
deal written about him and he of course
wrote a great deal and he was sort of he
figures in a novel of mine called Empire
if you want to see what I have done with
him I have a very funny scene when he he
announces that McKinley has been shot
and he comes rushing down and Henry
Adams the Adams azar staying up in New
England for the summer and McKinley's
been shot and their friends Theodore
Roosevelt is now president and Brooks
Adams and I whenever I was seen with a
real person like Brooks Adams I take it
from letters I take it from life
he came rushing down the lawn and he
said he will be greater than Trajan he
will be greater than all the great Roman
emperors and so on sort of him to Empire
but Brooks had all sorts of curious
notions I talked earlier in the program
about Shanxi Province in China
which is very rich in minerals and so on
he who controlled it would control the
world and that was a Brooks Adams
proposition he also figured out at the
time of the first world war he said
Germany is too small a country - he had
a funny funny image simile to swing the
hammers and some phrase like that if are
too small they'll find at the end of
this war they're only two great powers
standing United States and Russia which
is right on he is to be read and then
the deterioration of the democratic
process can't remember that was he or
Henry Adams or did he edit enry Adams
but I associate that with him but
getting me so well worth reading well
speaking of characters in your book I
think we might have sidestep to an
earlier caller's question about Dutch
and the technique of inserting fictional
characters into biography also edmund
morris the author is in that book as you
are in your most recent book the golden
age what do you think about this whole
technique and does it belong and
biography as opposed to historical
fiction well in starkville fiction is a
curious phrase if it's fiction it's not
history others history it's not fiction
I have worked out a blend over the years
in which my history is history the
historical figures do what they did and
say what they did pretty much then I
have made-up characters to mix with him
I know edmund morris lightly and it may
well be that he he might have picked up
something from me along the way about
the mixture I read Dutch but I gather
from what I've heard about it that he
makes himself a very major character I'm
a very small character in the Golden Age
I'm this just there at the end to bring
down the curtain and give my Prospero
speech
our revels now are ended and to
contemplate what is history what is real
what is fact I've got with it all
through the series of William Randolph
Hearst inventing wars and bending it
news and then historians working from
his inventions and then what is real and
I come back to Henry Adams image which
is all his energy and he had this image
of the Dynamo which would be the great
20th century god it is energy at his
force that matters and matter that
matters is force well may I get you to
reads just one of the paragraphs
while you're speaking about the closing
of this book this is your view of the
human race the last paragraph right
there as for the human case the
generation of men come and go and are in
eternity no more than bacteria upon a
luminous slide and the fall of a
republic or the rise of an empire so
significant to those involved is not
detectable upon the slide even were
there an interested eye to the whole
that steadily proliferating species
which would either end in time or with
luck becomes something else
since change the nature of life and its
hope and what do you mean with those
observations metamorphosis change
transformation before I get to that
point I've already got Aaron Burr coming
back and some of the characters are
coming back it's now the year 2000 and
we're in Ravello doing a TV program and
a young director who is Aaron Burr come
back it's a descendant of birth
and I asked him what are you going to do
this time since I'm not the writer
anymore oh he said it will because I'm
not going to bother with politics but
it'll be it'll be something different
more vast I said aw you mean the
Internet
no no he said larger than that I think
the next thing is a restructuring of the
human race physically that this is now a
possibility that we with genetic
experiments we can evolve a new kind of
human being now of course we can evolve
a monster or an angel or cross between
the two but I think if there's a human
race in a thousand years we won't look
anything like we do now I'm not saying
that in the book because I'm not going
to end with anything technical or pseudo
technical but if we are to survive
otherwise we will we will die I mean the
planet is clearly dying we're running
out of water in the air is diluted there
are too many of us and we've used up too
much of the planet
so either we escape to another planet
which we will so I use the image of
bacteria we're like bacteria the planet
is our host and we're eating it up
because they're too many of us so either
we die out or we transform ourselves
that's my message to the troops next
Gore Vidal's Albuquerque New Mexico mr.
Vidal first first I want to say that
throughout my life I've learned more
I've learned history and social critique
through the work that you have done and
I think I have read more books by you
than any other person of planet ever at
any time second I want to say something
about an experience I had 25 years ago
when I tried to meet you psychically and
I and yeah I ended up in the Beverly
Hills Hotel and maybe you'll recall that
moment and my friends were there and you
I told you this experience and you were
most gracious to me and I for that I'm
very appreciative I think the confidence
that I took in mind and thinking about
that I
do something to affect the life of
myself others the planet and being an
activist actually derived from that
moment of meeting you and I was I'm 50
today now my question 25 years later
from that time is that in your book that
seems to me that you actually transcend
time and space do you feel that there's
another energy that motivates you as
well as the research thank you for
contributing so much to my life in the
life of the people on this planet thank
you that's the second caller who has
attempted to make psychic connections
with you just happen to you a lot you're
making one now I don't know about this
other force we're certainly all
interconnected we all go back to the Big
Bang we're all units of energy that when
we go cold and dead entropy as they call
it within the elements that make us up
will be rearranged in new kinds of
energy new kinds of force so in that
sense we are agreeably immortal those
the consciousness that is Jane and the
consciousness that is Jagr is not going
to continue but the material the matter
that makes us up does go into new
arrangements and at the end of the
Golden Age I'm through the return of
Aaron Burr trying to show that something
is can be in the works and it's probably
going on we can say psychic we can say
is part of our common heritage of that
in it initial bang that started creation
what it is where it is we have still
don't know it's a piteous like being
handed a mystery story and you get
interested in and halfway through so
they take it away from you so we don't
need to know the end next calls from
Vicksburg Mississippi welcome hello
hello mr. Badal how are you I have a
two-part question and your wonderful
play I guess in 1960 the best man it was
Senator Joe Cantwell was he based upon
Senator McCarthy and certainly did you
have any say and in the catching of the
film in the lead played by Henry Fonda
and Cliff Robertson yes I worked with
the producers on the caste and Fonda was
marvelous and Cliff Robertson was the
best he's ever been as Cantwell Cantwell
was not based on Joe McCarthy but I mean
none of them are based on anybody
they are suggested by certain political
types and there's a Nick Sounion
ruthless type which is much closer I
suppose to senator Cantwell but the
interesting thing about the play and how
it works
when it works is the supposedly good guy
has a lot of things wrong with him and
the supposedly bad guy has a lot of good
things going Chris Noth is wonderful as
senator Cantwell and half the audience
thinks that he probably should be
President despite his ruthless amoral
ways and Spalding Gray who plays the
elegant Stephen Sounion style
candidate is one things wrong with him
that you might not want in a president
so the audience is I don't I don't tell
anybody what to think about characters I
obviously have opinions but I give the
evidence I give the characters autonomy
they say they take over they say and do
what what they must do unless they're
historical in which case I stay with the
agreed upon facts so I think it's a
personal to be boring if you knew what
you thought about your characters before
you wrote them and it will be very dull
if you had a message to deliver you just
let it evolve and then as you go over
you begin to see what what it is
done generally I find one rights to find
out what one thinks I find if I don't
right I don't think I just I sensate
that's about all Portland Oregon you're
next
good afternoon yes it is indeed an honor
to ask you a question mr. Badal actually
had two questions first you talked about
the deck of cards being very small and
I'd like to know more about the
relationships or the among the
presidents I know Franklin Roosevelt was
supposedly related to eleven presidents
number two had Ben Franklin and the
others in Paris failed to get French
help what would have been the result and
how long would have taken us to throw
off British rule thank you so much
that's a good question without the
French I don't think we could have done
it you know Washington for all of his a
really great great character and staying
power was not a very skillful general
thank God neither was Cornwallis so we
didn't have to Bonaparte's fighting each
other here but I had the French fleet
not come in at the end and decided the
whole thing we might have lost the
revolution and we might have gone on for
a time as a possession of England but as
as even the stupidest British government
realized you cannot have a colony 3,000
miles away whose population soon will be
larger than yours I mean it just it
would have fallen apart in other words
we would have had a republic later on
rather than immediately we might have
had a monarchy there were a lot of
monarchists and there was serious
discussion should George Washington at
George Washington to that name but not
George he might have had he been William
he might have become King I think he was
tempted but we were getting rid of
George the third for George the first I
mean that would send shivers down proto
populist spines
but it was all important French aid and
we got it and that was that small deck
of cards particularly the beginning
particularly people who've been here a
long time whether English from the
British Isles or a Dutch like Roosevelt
yes through intermarrying or whether
marriages you do get related to
everybody my relations are more on the
rednecks as in franklin roosevelt's were
more on the eastern harris aristocracy
which intermarried all along so all the
great Dutch families Beekman and so on
Roosevelt wasn't far more proud of being
related to the Beekman family which were
less distinguished in the 17th century
in the state of New York then he was of
being fifth cousin to itto roosevelt
combines work earlier you mentioned the
number of years that you were shut out
from the new york times today as you and
i are talking in this town pick up the
papers read by many both the New York
Times and Washington Post over huge your
new books do tend to reef review well I
read this one because I'm going to take
some action against the times I don't
quite know what but they're in for a bit
of punishment they gave the book the
golden age to a British journalist who
is Catholic has no subjects that I can
tell other than the glories of being and
sufferings of being gay and Marty
parrots of the New Republic brought him
over to everyone's surprised who had is
the New Republic I guess that didn't pan
out now he's a freelance journalist
The Times wanted an all-out attack on
the Golden Age so they give it to
somebody who knows no American history
and he makes so many mistakes I forget
what he says about me the mistakes that
he makes no editor who knows anything
would allow in their paper he writes it
is silly when gore Vidal says the
Japanese wanted to surrender before the
atomic bomb at Hiroshima everybody knows
they wanted in May 45 the bomb was
August of 45 every everyone who knows
anything about that war he knows nothing
knows the Japanese were trying to
surrender they were defeated and the
only sticking point was that Roosevelt
had said unconditional surrender as
Lincoln had said in the Civil War and
they had a condition which was they
could retain the Emperor and they were
still arguing about that Roosevelt is
now dead Harry Truman goes to Potsdam he
goes back he's wants to go back on all
the agreements made at Yalta by
Roosevelt in the middle of his meetings
with Stalin Stalin his promise to come
into the war against Japan suddenly in
the middle of meetings he gets a message
that a bomb has gone off near Los Alamos
in the desert and there and the atom
bomb works he now knows the war in Japan
will be over any time he drops it
meanwhile the Japanese are trying to
surrender and they're dragging it we're
dragging our feet and he wants to drop
the bomb to frighten Stalin that was
that was the whole point to the bomb
Japan was there was no Tokyo the b-29s
had eliminated the city so this was a
very brutal act of diplomacy I guess is
a polite word for it to scare Stalin and
to say look we're the masters of the
world now we have this extraordinary
weapon and you don't take you years
because you're too primitive anyway this
joker who should not be allowed to write
about these things or if he is he
certainly should be heavily edited and
corrected doesn't know this he knows
nothing indeed about the subject of the
book which this
Roosevelt administration and Harry
Truman and Dean Acheson I have a
marvelous aria by Herbert Hoover well I
don't make up Herbert Hoover aria or
Roosevelt aria I take it from what
they've actually written or said and
it's a it's a quite as passage if you've
got he's got it in his review and I've
come to quite admire Hoover in some way
the Hoover was a very perceptive man and
now he acts as though this reviewer as
though I have made up the speech for
Hoover when Hoover himself wrote it I am
certain that the next war will apps will
transform us absolutely and he means
World War two
I see more power to the great
corporations more power to the
government less power to the people
that's what I fear because once this
starts it is irreversible you can't
extend the mastery of the government
over the daily life of the people
without making government the master
those people's souls and thoughts the
way the fascist the Bolsheviks have done
in a serpentine way Franklin is going in
the very same direction that they have
gone in and I think he knows exactly
what he's doing
now my dear Herbert Hoover was a bitter
man who had just been had been defeated
badly by Roosevelt in the 1932 election
he was also very very conservative which
I thought it was nice to give a
conservative point of view since I'm
thought to be liberal and so now you
have a quotation from Herbert Hoover and
he thinks that I make up everything he's
trying to tell use the authority of the
New York Times they all don't believe
anything he says
hoo-wee never said that let's read all
talking well this is saying that what I
do is totally a fraud and that's
actionable what would make you happy
from the near times Oh stead fold well
with regard to this review when you say
it's actionable uh well we'll see what
action might be taken I'll tell you one
thing if I wrote a letter to the New
York Times
correcting all of the distortions and
just lies that he has written they
wouldn't publish it
they never published letters that
criticized them they just get lost
Renata Adler did a book about the New
Yorker in which she mentions rather
unpleasantly the editor of this book
section and The Times took revenge on
Renata Adler on her little book on a New
Yorker and wrote she's seven or eight
pieces different parts of the paper
attacking her in the book over and over
and over again
she wrote two letters at the Times
trying to correct them they wouldn't
publish them so she went to harper's
magazine and did it her entire attack on
the New York Times and what had tried to
do to silence her this is a bad
newspaper Virgin Islands thanks for
waiting your honor now mr. B though can
you comment on the influence of
Freemasonry on the American government
and the possibilities of American in
police imperialism might well be an
extension of British imperialism I don't
know much about Freemasonry my
grandfather Vidal was a 33rd degree
Mason I never knew what that meant
I don't well I don't know it's a secret
society allegedly it certainly had great
power in England the Prince of Wales was
almost always automatically the nominal
head of the Freemasons and we've had
many important Americans have been
Freemasons but I would think if there
was a smoking gun somebody would have
noticed it by now
I haven't who every doll is spending
three hours with us on our in-depth
program it's afternoon we have about 25
minutes left in that conversation sex
calls from Sacramento
conversation caller you obviously have
your TV set turned up too loudly why
don't you turn it down and then go ahead
oh I don't think we're going to work
with that call let's move on if we can
please to our next call from st. Louis
hello mister of it all I want to thank
you so much for your book on Lincoln I
the first biography I ever read was in
first grade was about him and I then
read everything I could about him and
when I read your book it made him and
his flesh for me and it was just an
absolute wonderful experience my
question for you you've very much
disappointed me when you said well I
like to write about the Mexican War but
I don't have that time to research any
longer who can you recommend these days
as let's say someone who's going to take
on your mantle so to write these
historical novels that do indeed put put
flesh and breath into a magnificent
history that's it's so much better than
any any story could ever be can you
recommend anybody that I can be looking
forward to reading their books since you
are disappointing me so much by saying
that you're not going to write another
well I don't read much historical
fiction because I have to read so much
history but I think for your purposes
you know let's let us hope that in the
near future we're getting some very good
young historians are coming along and I
think that they will fill in which what
you want filled in in your view of the
past they're much smarter and sharper
than let's say 20 30 years ago you don't
have the Dumas Malone as you know he
brought that huge life of Jefferson
which he had nothing interesting to say
about the most interesting after the
president looked to history look to
biography
I think that's of Richfield what are you
reading right now I'm reading
Trevelyan life of john bright and john
bride was Quakers in Parliament in
England he was liberal in the 1870s and
a superb writer and Spurs speaker and a
great influence on my grandfather can
you think of this boy from Mississippi
who goes out to Indian Territory invents
a state called Oklahoma and spends his
time reading through a surrogate John
bright and all of these English radicals
that's whatever you San Jose yes
mr. Vidal um I'm one of these late
readers I always read books about six
years after they've been published and
I'm a enjoying Empire I'm particularly
enjoying your description of Theodore
Roosevelt with his clicking teeth I
guess my question has to do with the
American aristocracy every time I
mention it I'm told that I'm engaging in
class warfare
my daughter is applying for college and
she has a 3.8 GPA a very high SAT and
she was basically advised that her
chances of getting into Yale were nil
yet George Bush with a C average in high
school gets into Yale with mediocre
grades at Yale by his own admission gets
him to Harvard Business School for the
rest of his career he's basically
protected by corporate interests who
continued to fund his campaign and I
guess my question is one that never
seems to be discussed is what is the
state of the American aristocracy and if
there's time how does it differ with the
British aristocracy having having lived
in Britain do you do you agree with me
my having lived in Britain do you agree
with me that at least the British
aristocracy has a redeeming quality that
everybody admits it's there and that by
right they get accepted to eat
and not by supposes merit thank you
well we certainly have a very durable
aristocracy there's enough meritocracy
that people join the aristocracy both
here and in England England is always
taking in new people to have new blood
but the heart of an aristocracy are the
schools and this is interesting you use
the example of your daughter and use the
example of Bush who went to Andover and
Yale I went to Exeter and would have
gone to Harvard had I not chosen the
army instead it's the schools are what
control the opinion of the children of
the rich and/or powerful I had a
stepbrother who was going to inherit a
lot of money and he was sent to Groton
that's where I've gotten st. marks and
so on those schools are invented for
those who will be rich to make them into
not only into gentlemen of scholars but
to inculcate certain values opinion I
come back to David Hume is how opinion
is formed in the ruling class they know
if you're sent to Groton what they're
going to get in the way of moral and
political training what their view of
the world will be I belong to the ruling
class I'm a stepbrother but I'm not
going to inherit any money so I'm sent
to Exeter which is for the bright boys
of the ruling class who will eventually
work for the rich boys and we will
become judges senators editors of the
New York Times many fields are open to
us bankers but we are the sort of
apparatchiks and not properly speaking
except by birth a member of the ultimate
class well that's how it's done and
that's how they continue it
there's always been a move in England
where as you point out they know about
the upper classes and we're not told we
have the most intelligent upper class
I've ever seen or at least overall they
are nobody knows they're there they own
the newspapers and newspapers aren't
going to give the game away who really
owns what who really controls what who
controls opinion and to be there and
never be named I mean people like
Spengler and so on have done marvelous
works but nothing really gets through
the people at large and so they go on
and on
occasionally a maverick appears among
them I was one and there are others but
by and large it's a closed corporation
there's a very good guy if you want to
read more about this called G William
Dom Hoff do em h o FF he teaches at
Santa Cruz or used to a University of
California who rules America he's
written three or four of those books
what he does he goes through
corporations and he gets lists of
directors then he goes through the
social registers and finds their names
and then he starts to find what clubs
they belong to where they went on to
college and he begins to construct you
begin to know all their names they they
become sort of friends that you don't
have and would we likely find them on
the list of invitees to this and
previous white houses of course some
more than others you know now over the
course of television so high somewhat
cruder sort of millionaires coming to
the White House I don't think you'll see
many melons going there or Rockefellers
but you will see movie moguls
next is Ogunquit Maine are you there an
operator in the line or circle yes go
ahead okay Lucas will you create a line
hello caller go ahead please yes I'm a
very interesting program thank you very
much for taking a cola my question for
mr. Vidal I have never read a gore Vidal
novel and wonder and
opinion sir where should I start well I
don't know if what we've been talking
about largely about which is the
American Empire and the Republic for
which it does not stand I'd start with
Empire which is Theodore Roosevelt and
Hearst and it's sort of a duel between
two Titans will Roosevelt through his
strenuousness and empire building and
the seizure of the Philippine Islands
and Cuba is he going to really be the
Augustus of a new great new world empire
or is William Randolph Hearst who
controls opinion and who can make him or
break him or so he thinks
be the titular deity of the Empire and
it's a duel between these two great
figures throughout the book and it's
kind of funny to have you a favorite
among all of these rich choosing among
your children to use next calls from
Costa Mesa California
I could have tuned into the both of you
thank you a question for mr. of it all I
tuned in a few minutes ago and heard you
almost lively toss out the comments
about the Japanese trying to surrender
before the atomic bomb was passed and
although I'm not a learned man or a
scholar ever at dozens of memoirs and
books about the subject and although the
might events and behind-the-scenes
negotiations with the Swiss it seems
that there was a not much not much
thinking that the surrender terms were
were really taken seriously by the
Americans and so I just wonder how you
tossed that comment off and I just
didn't think that they were really
trying to surrender at that time well
you're not supposed to think they were
trying to surrender it is the will of
the American government and the school
teachers who follow the lead of the
government largely because they have to
because of the huge allocations for
research and development at universities
get which affects the humanities that is
the history departments as well
anticipating such questions yours I will
give you a little reading list
first of all in May of 1945 Allen Dulles
you made a reference to the Swiss
meetings he was I think head of the OSS
part of the OSS was having conversations
with the Japanese about the conditions
of surrender
we had said unconditional surrender but
basically we were probably willing to
adjust it
they had a condition they wanted to keep
the Emperor so I would propose that you
read let me see here the decision to use
the a-bomb by Edwin Fogelman fo GTL ma
Anna's very thorough and also
unconditional surrender by John D chat l
CH a PP e ll this is one of the most
thorough studies of what preceded the
dropping of the bomb by the 28th of May
the president had been assured that the
Japanese were defeated
Admiral Nimitz said we don't need to
invade and we certainly don't need to
use nuclear weapons they will surrender
in the course of the summer
now that's nimitz who was the admiral of
the fleet in the Pacific at the time
Stimson the Secretary of War and the
Roosevelt had been secretary state under
Herbert Hoover and Stimpson asked by
committee was he surprised on the
Japanese attacked Pearl Harbor this was
earlier but leading up to it the way the
Japanese mind allegedly worked he said I
was not surprised letting on that is
because I knew the situation best having
been Secretary of State that indeed if
put in a box and now shifting from the
atomic bomb to Pearl Harbor
that Roosevelt provoked Japan into
attacking us in 1940 he got reelected
by saying that no sons of yours will
ever fight in a foreign war unless we
are attacked and that was his campaign
pledge the American people he got
elected president he wants to go into
the war on the side of England which is
being battered by the German air force
Francis fought eighty percent of the
American people do not want to go to war
any more than they wanted to go to war
in 1917 he does his best to try and
convince them and virtuously since I'm
on the side of England against Germany I
too was all for the idea that we give
them Destroyers material help Russia to
the American people aren't going to buy
a war the only way he can get in Japan
has made a tripartite agreement with
Germany and with Italy each will help
the other in case of war Roosevelt is
now deliberately moving Japan into
attacking us finally in August I think
it was of 1941 he gave them an ultimatum
through Cordell Hull his secretaries say
they had to Japanese ambassadors had
come to Washington and he said you must
withdraw the mainland of Asia since 37
they've been trying to conquer China and
they already conquered Manchuria if not
we will put an embargo on you and they
were getting most of their oil came from
us and scrap metal they didn't have
metal of their own they imported if you
don't obey this ultimatum they
immediately prepared for an attack on
Pearl Harbor
apologist for Roosevelt in this instance
by the way I am Pro Roosevelt and pro
New Deal I'm anti American Empire
apologist for Roosevelt say that he
expected the attack to come at Manila or
some other place he didn't expect this
massive all-out attack on Pearl Harbor
which cost us 3,000 lives it came to
pass on the 7th of December 1941 a week
before the attack he wrote a letter it's
all a matter of history to Wendell
Willkie the Republican opponent his
Republican opponent in the previous
election and he said we will be attacked
probably before next Monday and we were
attacked on Sunday now he could write
that a week before to Wendell Willkie
why didn't he write it to the commanders
at Pearl Harbor the only warning that
they were given by the War Department
was to watch out for saboteurs that they
were around and a funny order came to
move some of the newer ships out of
Pearl Harbor and send off in a westerly
direction I hope that answers you
Bloomington Indiana was about 10 minutes
left to go you're on the air thank you I
really appreciate the opportunity to
speak to gore Vidal and I appreciate
what c-span is doing in exposing
different points of view I have a
question about three specific
individuals first of all Howard Zinn I'd
like to know if you're a friend of his
and if you approve of his work
second of all Allen Ginsberg of I'd like
to know what your opinion is on his role
as the spokesman not just for radical
causes but particularly for the cause of
tolerance for sexual diversity and
finally I'd like to revisit the subject
of Ralph Nader where I really don't
understand your opinions because the
opinions you've expressed about the
duopoly are virtually identical to
Nader's and when you say Gore is thicker
than later are we to take this to mean
that you're supporting him because
of familiar connections because he
supports NAFTA GATT corporate manage
trade he is totally inadequate on the
environment that helped and he
dependence he has a dependence on
corporate money so I'd like to hear your
your view on that well I certainly
sympathize with your position and you
haven't said anything that I regard is
untrue about Gore it's a bit more to
Nader that I well remember when I was
with dr. Spock I was co-chairman the
People's Party 1968 to about hundred of
70-72
and nadir made no statement about the
Vietnam War he avoided it and that was
the great issue of art of that period of
time I'm not pointing a finger at him
I'm just saying that I would find him a
more attractive figure politically if
indeed he had taken a stand no I I see I
I but I've been through this already I
yes there's a good point in making a not
a duopoly but a third party but her
isn't it duopoly there's a monopoly the
Democratic Party the Republican Party
are the same party they're the corporate
party of America they're paid for by the
same people
yes Gore is part of that but between an
intelligent do Appa list or monopolist I
should say and an unintelligent one like
Bush I'm afraid I would vote for despite
or because perhaps of the family
connection for the more intelligent one
one of those two is going to be elected
and it better be Gore of the two that
he's totally unsatisfactory on many
issues I care about you care about is
something else and I don't even know if
it's personal
I don't know I'm I can't speak for him
but I would certainly say he's part of
the most corrupt political culture that
the United States has ever seen we've
had some bad patches before but this is
like nothing else he is part of a system
can he transcend it I doubt it
but I hope you can that's the best I can
do
Howard Zinn or Allen Ginsberg I don't
know who Howard Zinn is historian Allen
Ginsberg was an old old friend of mine
and he's wonderful he on sexual
diversity he was wonderful and he was a
charming man and I miss is not being
alive next call spring bills and soaring
yes sir
do you talk about there being a police
state and that sort of thing having
developed after World War two two major
futuristic police states if you will
have been written about and celebrated
quite a lot the century in terms of or
what I'm speaking of is of course or
well and and Aldous Huxley's brave new
world and of the to which do you feel
that we're more approaching well I must
say elders actually sounded a lot more
fun than ours with that soma everybody
was taking as I suppose we can say the
drugs are the equivalent today but I
don't I don't see us going in either of
those directions everything changed
after 89 we lost our enemy takes a lot
of money to create opinion as powerful
as opinion our ownership created for us
in the Russians are coming and communism
is everywhere when it isn't anywhere at
least not in the United States it wasn't
I see it more as too few people have too
much money too many people have too
little and the grass penis and the
palatal power of corporate America if
you own the New York Times if you own
the present and if you own the Congress
there is no way for the people to
express themselves there's no there's no
means of her address you can't say we've
got a great out of the West out of the
Monongahela Valley came a man a Titan
you can't do that anymore
times won't report the great new leader
his speeches will not be recorded
they have silenced just about every
dissenting voice in the country and done
it very very successfully
we have c-span here from which we should
all be very thankful that at least they
are able to fall as it were between the
cracks of a pretty monolithic structure
there isn't much else so does the
internet give you hope that I don't
understand the internet I mean I don't
know what it's all about
I don't use it I look at it I've seen
several sites with my name on it and one
is run by a guy who seems to be making
money out of it somebody told me I don't
know yes it anything that one person or
one corporation cannot control is
obviously going to be free or
potentially free so maybe that is an
answer I don't but not my subject Miami
Oh mr. Vidal let me say it's an honor to
speak to you I I came to you at 25 years
old late in life but fortunately before
the establishment then the propaganda of
the admittedly impressive job I was able
to turn a once idealistic 14 year old
into a bitter and crimando and age 27
but a question in a comment first off
I'd like to ask if you think it's
possible in my lifetime for someone to
campaign and have a successful shot at
being president without abiding to the
agenda of the Jesus Christ or is it to
say someone who is an agnostic who sees
religion and what it's done in and
campaign on that trend and the second
point is that I think you're much too
harsh on your old friend John Kennedy
yeah he has his idealism still rings
true for today and I think in in light
of the revisionist the last 20 years he
comes across as a better president
certainly in Y allistic figure than the
crop that is today thank you very much
well I'm Jack Kennedy I knew him pretty
well and he was one of the most charming
man I've ever known one of the funniest
but he first of all he didn't have a
liberal bone in his body it was ambition
ambition and he really believed in the
Cold War
you know Truman in the Eisenhower or two
old pros
they knew the Cold War had been cooked
up by crewmen the Russians are coming so
that we could establish NATO the CIA
militarized the economy control our own
people not to mention everybody else who
falls under our sway they're very
cynical in fact Eisenhower in his
farewell to the nation in January 61
when Jack came to office he warns of the
military-industrial complex he also
something that people forget he warned
of the influence on the universities of
of the military-industrial complex he
said once a university accepts a large
federal allocation of funds that
University ceases to be free or you
should have free inquiry etcetera and
you will not have it because of the
necessity they will feel I'm
interpreting now not khorium that they
will feel the government wants and this
is in fact the history departments they
are serving of history even their
history like Kennedy they're serving it
up in order to create a kind of false
picture of a country that of anybody can
be president and land of opportunity of
the people by the people for the people
all that has been erased in the last 50
years there is nothing left of it except
false histories and hagiographies
and was his other question it was about
winning the White House elevated as an
agnostic I think you'd better keep quiet
about it because Jefferson got caught on
that and Lincoln almost got caught
both were agnostics Lincoln came to use
God a lot in speeches in his last year
or two
all the almighty and God he never
mentioned Jesus and all of the
Federalist Papers the founding fathers
God is mentioned only twice Jesus has
not mentioned at all you might tell some
of your Jesus Christ and Friends of the
founders of the country we're men of the
Enlightenment and by and large they were
either agnostic atheist or not
interested
they they they nearly got Jefferson who
finally said he was a deist which means
nothing at all I just thought there was
probably a God and slithered out of that
one Lincoln wrote a book called in a
pamphlet called infidelity meaning not
believing in God and he showed it to
Herndon his law partner in her and said
this all-out attack on Christianity
great stuff said her and and now burn it
because you're going to be President so
don't publish infidelity our three hours
is finished
I regret to say hallelujah as we close
let me show you once again Gore Vidal's
latest novel it is called the Golden Age
it is the seventh and final in this
series of books chronicling American
history published by doubleday and
available across the country in
bookstores mr. Badal thank you for
spending so much time with us we
appreciate it
you can see book TVs three-hour in-depth
interview with author playwright and
essayist gore Vidal again tonight at
midnight